Lieferung Füllung der Gasspeicher Aufbau
von fsius das spielt heute kaum noch
eine Rolle in der öffentlichen Debatte
und ich erwähne das nur um zu zeigen wie
weit wir gekommen sind in diesem Land
durch eine gemeinsame ich werde darauf
zurückkommen gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung
der verschiedenen Akteure in Deutschland
und ich erwähne ist zweitens
für wen ist zweitens weil Teile
der gegenwärtigen konjunkturellen
Schwächephase herausfordernden
Situationen die wir haben unmittelbar
unmittelbar mit diesen damals virulenten
und heute beherrschbaren Problemen zu
tun haben Deutschland ist eine
Exportnation darauf sind wir stolz das
hat unseren Wohlstand in den letzten Weg
haben nach oben gebracht aber natürlich
sind wir darauf angewiesen dass die
Exportmärkte offenstehen dass China
nicht mehr nur der nette Handelspartner
ist dürfte zwischen allen klar geworden
sein deutschland ist ein
hochindustrielles Land das noch immer
eine Energie intensive Industrie hat und
natürlich gibt es einen Zusammenhang
wenn ungefähr die Hälfte der Energie aus
Russland wegfällt mit hohen
Energiepreisen und wir leiden unter der
Inflation die nicht überraschend kommt
denn wenn die Hälfte der Energie
wegfällt und zu hören Preisen besorgt
werden muss dann treibt es natürlich die
Inflation nach oben
was heißt viele von denen Problemen die
wir im Moment haben und die haben wir
hängen eine ursächlichen Zusammenhang
mit den Turbulenzen mit dem
fürchterlichen Angriffskrieg von Putin
auf die Ukraine immer noch und auch wenn
die Trolle von Putin ist nicht wahrhaben
wollen es war ja von Anfang an das Ziel
von Putin die wirtschaftliche Lage in
Europa zu destabilisieren gut dass wir
ihm in den Armen gefallen sind gemeinsam
in den Armen gefallen sind
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren diese
Probleme treffen auf strukturelle
Probleme
auf strukturelle Probleme die Bürokratie
fehlende Arbeitskräfte fehlende
Digitalisierung wir treffen um diese
strukturellen Probleme zu beheben glaube
ich gibt es drei politische
Grundhaltung die uns helfen würden da
gemeinsam durchzukommen und ich betone
noch einmal die Gemeinsamkeit das heißt
natürlich nicht Einstimmigkeit sondern
gemeinsam Analyse und den Willen zu
kooperieren erstens Selbstkritik das
gilt natürlich für mich und für meine
Partei Dinge die wir besser machen
können müssen wir besser machen und kann
man einräumen dass man sie in der
Vergangenheit vielleicht anders gesehen
hat die Situation hat sich halt völlig
geändert ich will aber auch kein Held
daraus machen das ist Grund zur
Selbstkritik auch bei anderen gibt das
sollte keine Schande sein wenn man seine
eigenen Position hinterfragt oder
einräumt dass man sich gehört hat
zweitens die Kraft für Differenzierung
wenn man nur den Hammer als Instrumenten
nimmt sieht man nur Nägel so ist es aber
nicht ich habe es eben angedeutet die
Situation ist differenziert und sie
erfordert differenzierte politische auch
wirtschaftspolitische Antworten und
drittens das gemeinsame suchen das
gemeinsame suchen heißt wer Vielfalt zu
Gegensätzen stilisiert gibt die
politische Mitte Preis und ich knüpfe an
die Worte von Katharina dröge gestern
und wenn ihr mich an die Union sie
werden es in Bayern erleben dass genau
diese Politik zu einer Preisgabe der
politischen Mitte führt und das wird in
letzter Konsequenz den
Wirtschaftsstandort Bayern extrem
Schwächen
und es entspricht nicht der Wirklichkeit
ich freue mich über die Unterstützung
gerade von
unionsministerpräsidentin bei dem
industriestrompreis und ich räume ein
oder finde es gut dass die Union
Vorstöße macht das länger zu arbeiten
politisch intensiv intensiviert wird es
gibt die Möglichkeit zu Kooperation wenn
man sie denn will entgegen von manchmal
mäßig intellektuell klugen Bierzelt
reden sehr geehrte Damen und Herren raus
aus der Komfortzone der selbst
Zufriedenheit das muss das Motto unserer
Zeit sein wenn wir unseren Wohlstand
verteidigen wenn wir unseren Wohlstand
erneuern wollen dann heißt es dass wir
aktiv handeln müssen und uns nicht
Vorträge halten wie man wohl in der
Vergangenheit besser gehandelt hätte
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
bedrückend ist
[Applaus]
rückblickend die selbst Zufriedenheit
die zukunftsbinde selbst Zufriedenheit
mit der wir in die Situation
hineingegangen sind noch bedrückend ist
aber wie die teilweise über kompensiert
wird durch ein defätistisches schlecht
redende Standorts Deutschlands wir haben
und ich habe es gerade hergeleitet wir
haben Probleme Probleme die ursächlich
mit der geopolitischen Situation und mit
hausgemachten Problemen zusammenhängen
das heißt aber nicht dass alles schlecht
ist wir sind ein starker Standort wir
sind ein hoch
interessanter Standort für ausländische
Investoren wir haben das gerade gehört
vom Bundeskanzler gestern 80 Milliarden
Euro stehen in der Pipeline von
Investitionen in Deutschland über 100
Millionen Euro die anderen Messenger gar
nicht wir haben eine große
finanzpolitische Feuerkraft wir haben
den Geist der Zusammenarbeit des
kooperatismus zwischen Sozialpartnern
und und Ländern und wir haben natürlich
die Möglichkeit siehe letztes Jahr zu
diesem Jahr Dinge besser zu machen dass
sie mich kurz auf die Bürokratie die in
Deutschland packt zu sprechen kommen wir
sind ja längst dabei ist zu tun mit mit
dem Bundesland Nordrhein-Westfalen
führen wir gerade praxis-checks zur
endbürokratisierung bei
Unternehmensgründung durch mit Bayern
treffen wir uns morgen um praxis-checks
bei der Nachhaltigkeitsberichterstattung
und der verschlankheit durchzuführen mit
dem Land Baden-Württemberg sind wir
dabei die Beschleunigung beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien von der Praxis her
zu überprüfen und zu entbürokratisieren
wir sind doch schon längst dabei das zu
tun und arbeiten gut zwischen Bund und
Land zusammen das heißt doch dass wir
die Kraft zur Zusammenarbeit haben
können
und wenn wir wenn ich das eben gerade
richtig gehört der Bereich das nicht na
ja ich habe ja eben
angemahnt vielleicht ein bisschen
selbstkritisch zu sein und wenn wir
überreicht das nicht kurz einmal reden
[Musik]
die Bilanz der Vergangenheit die wir
vorgefunden haben Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren politisch verschlägt
Digitalisierung bis zum UMTS Ausbau
schlecht gemacht die Arbeitskräfte
Einwanderung mit Absicht verhindert die
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt von
Fachkräften nicht gewollt die
Erneuerbaren mutwillig verzögert den
Netzausbau verhindert dass das ist
reicht das nicht natürlich reicht das
alles nicht sonst werden wir ja sonst
werden wir ein Land ohne Probleme aber
aber mit mit einer Geschwindigkeit wie
nie zuvor löst diese Bundesregierung die
Probleme sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
der Wille der Wille zur Kooperation
heißt politische Gegensätze zu
akzeptieren aber das gemeinsame zu
suchen der Wille den Standort
Deutschland zu stärken heißt auf die
Kraft dieses Landes zu setzen und sie zu
entfesseln lösen wir uns von den
schlenderjahren der Vergangenheit
entfesseln wir die wirtschaftliche Kraft
Deutschlands erneuern mit den Wohlstand
danke schön
der Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz zu Robert Habeck ist hier
mal unter seiner Zeit geblieben die
eigentlich zur Verfügung gehabt hätte um
seinen Etat für das Jahr 2024
vorzustellen und zu verteidigen aber
etwas Tempo schadet ja im Prinzip nicht
auch beim Thema Wirtschaft Jens Spahn
ist Fraktionsvize der Unionsfraktion und
der nächste Redner vorgestern der
tatsächliche Vizekanzler gestern der
Kanzler heute der eigentliche
Vizekanzler drei verschiedene reden für
dreimal ein verschiedenes Publikum denn
jeweils klatscht der nur die andere
Fraktion die eigene Fraktion bei den
anderen rührt sich hier jeweils die Hand
nicht und man hat den Eindruck man hat
den Eindruck es sind drei verschiedene
Welten in denen sie leben auch wenn man
ihnen genau zugehört hat der
Wirtschaftsminister hat man nicht den
Eindruck dass sie wirklich in der realen
Welt leben wir sind in der Rezession wir
sind das einzige Industrieland der
schrumpft das einzige was wächst in
Deutschland sind die Arbeitslosenzahlen
und die Zahl der Insolvenzen wir haben
Rekord Inflationen zig Millionen
Deutsche haben weniger Kaufkraft jeden
Monat davon haben sie hier kein Wort
gesagt sie leben echt in einer anderen
weltherminister
und ja sie waren selbstkritisch im
Politik philosophischen aber im
konkreten haben wir hier wenig gehört
und Herr Vizekanzler
ich hätte gerne was gehört was sie zum
kanzlervorschlag von gestern sagen ihr
näher ein kleiner Halbsatz ihr
Dauerstreit mit dem Finanzminister ist
doch der Hauptgrund warum diese
Regierung im Chaos versinkt die zweite
Frage die sich dabei stellt ist worüber
reden wir eigentlich bei diesem
deutschland-pakt das was uns gestern im
Nachgang als Deutschland verkauft werden
sollte ist doch eigentlich nur ein
Päckchen ein Bonsai Paket eine
Auflistung von Projekten bei denen sie
seit Monaten nicht vorankommen
Vorschläge der Länder die doch bisher an
ihnen Scheitern das ist bestenfalls ein
PR-Gag aber nur eine neue Verpackung
aber nicht neue Politik
wenn sie wirklich tun wollen was nötig
ist dann schlage ich Ihnen gleich drei
Punkte vor ein Pakt für Wachstum die
Energiekosten müssen runter
Kernkraftwerke wieder ans Netz damit wir
mehr Angebote haben Stromsteuer runter
Netzentgelte runter für Industrie
Mittelstand Handwerk Steuern runter für
die die in Deutschland investieren das
wäre ein praktische Wachstum der ein
Unterschied macht
ein Pakt für Leistungen und Fleisch eine
belastungsbremse bei 40% Sozialabgaben
Steuerfreiheit für Überstunden und für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner die noch
arbeiten gehen damit die die zusätzlich
mit anpacken auch was davon haben eine
Reform beim Bürgergeld nach dem Prinzip
wir arbeiten kann sollte arbeiten das
wäre ein praktische Fleiß der ein
Unterschied macht für Deutschland
und angesichts der Lage in der wir sind
ja auch ein Pakt für sichere Grenzen und
gegen illegale Migration sichere
Herkunftsstaaten damit die Verfahren
schneller sind schneller abgeschoben
werden kann Sachleistungen statt
Geldleistungen damit wir auch dort die
Fehler Anreize reduzieren
Grenzkontrollen an der Grenze zu Polen
Tschechien der Schweiz machen sie
endlich ihren Job legen Sie konkrete
Maßnahmen vor für Wachstum Leistung und
Sicherheit sinnvolle Gesetze sind noch
nie an der Union gescheitert sie
scheitern an ihre eigenen Koalition und
das ist das Problem das ist das
eigentliche Problem
und das bringt mich zur vielleicht
eigentlichen Frage rund um diesen
deutschlandpackt denn worauf wollte der
Bundeskanzler eigentlich hinaus in
Wahrheit war das doch gestern ein
Offenbarungseid denn das Problem ist
nicht dass wir eine Krise haben die den
großen Schulterschluss benötigt das
Problem ist dass wir eine Regierung
haben die in der Krise nicht
funktioniert
der deutschlandpakt ist in Wahrheit ein
Misstrauensvotum des Kanzlers gegen
seine eigene Koalition denn vieles in
diesem Fakt könnten sie mit ihrer denn
vieles von ihrem Pakt könnten sie mit
ihrer Mehrheit doch hier einfach machen
doch ihre Koalition ist zerstritten und
zerrüttet sie vertrauen einander nicht
mehr 80 Prozent der Deutschen Vertrauen
ihrer Regierung nicht mehr das was sie
hier seit Monaten machen dieses
zerrüttete Vertrauen ist ein
konturprogramm für die Populisten und
das ist das eigentliche Problem und
davon müssen wir in den Diskussionen
hier tatsächlich ausgehen
und dafür liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dafür ist die Lösung nicht dass die
Opposition die Regierung stützt wenn die
Regierung für das was zu tun ist keine
eigene Mehrheit mehr hat braucht es
keinen packt dann müssen Sie ernsthaft
über ihre Regierungsfähigkeit nachdenken
machen sie
machen sie als Ampel ihre Arbeit oder
lassen Sie andere sie machen aber hören
sie auf mit diesem Popanz wir sind
mitten in der Krise es ist Zeit für
Taten und für weniger Gerede
und für die Union für die SPD-Fraktion
Entschuldigung hat das Wort Frank junge
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren Herr Spahn zunächst möchte ich
anmerken dass trotz mit markigen Worten
vorgetragen und je öfter Sie das sagen
wird es aber trotzdem nicht realer und
wahrer und der zweite Aspekt der noch
mal zu bemerken ist ist wenn Sie unsere
Gesetze kritisieren und einfordern dass
sie sinnvoll sein sollen dann würde ich
vorschlagen machen Sie doch selbst kluge
Vorschläge die in dieser Krise dann auch
diesen Land helfen und zwar anzubringen
mit dem Blick auf die Einschätzung der
Krise und das dort nichts funktioniert
hat will ich ihn noch mal sagen dass wir
vor 18 Monaten mit Beginn der
Zeitenwende und dem Überfall von Putin
auf die Ukraine vor einer Prognose
gestanden haben eine tiefe Rezession zur
eilen die Optimisten sprachen von -5 und
die die Pessimisten von
-10%, eine Insolvenzwelle sollte kommen
und die Arbeitslosigkeit massiv steigen
wenn wir heute wenn wir heute auf das
schauen was wir haben dann liegt die
Rezession bei 0,4 Prozent es gab es gab
keine insolvenzelle und wenn wir die
Arbeitslosigkeit von August 2023
vergleichen mit August 2022 dann liegt
das fast auch gleich im Niveau also ein
Horrorszenario wie sie es vielleicht
gerne hätten kann ich dort nicht
feststellen und warum ist die
Entwicklung so weil wir entschlossen
gehandelt haben weil wir über
dreistellige Milliardenbeträge die
Familien und Bürger entlastet haben an
wir haben die Unternehmen steuerlich
entlastet und wir haben mit enormer
finanzieller Kraft dafür gesorgt in
nutzbringende und nachhaltige
Infrastruktur zu investieren und das
alles hat am Ende dazu geführt dass wir
heute diesen Stand haben und wer heute
sich hinstellt wie sie es tun um am Ende
dieser
Vorgehensweise der aktuellen Lage
komplett zu ignorieren wer völlig
ignoriert von wo wir gekommen sind und
heute sind wer also ausschließt dass wir
unter diesem Aspekt in der Krise schon
gute Entwicklung genommen haben der
verweigert sich nur nicht nur der
Wahrnehmung der Realität der betreibt
ganz bewusst Angstmacherei und der liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen schadet unserer
Wirtschaft und redet den
Rechtspopulisten den Mund
unabhängig davon das will ich auch ganz
klar sagen können wir mit der
gegenwärtigen wirtschaftlichen Lage
nicht zufrieden sein das ist allen klar
die hier ohne Alarmismus an diese
Situation herangehen und vor diesem
Hintergrund wird der vorgelegte
Haushaltsentwurf der Bundesregierung
diesen Ansprüchen gerecht wir haben mit
90 Milliarden Euro inklusive KTF in
diesem nächsten Haushaltsjahr eine
Investitionsquote im Haushalt die ist
noch nie zuvor gegeben hat warum ist das
wichtig weil wir mit diesem Geld Anreize
setzen können wir können Investitionen
in nachhaltige Bereiche voranbringen wir
können der Wirtschaft Verlässlichkeit
und Planungssicherheit bieten und genau
das sind die Instrumente die unsere
Wirtschaft gegenwärtig braucht mit dem
Etat des bmwk stehen alleine mit den
Mitteln des ktfs 40 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung und auch das sind
Größenordnungen die so vorher noch nicht
gegeben hat lassen Sie mich zwei drei
Dinge erwähnen die insbesondere aus
meiner Sicht von großer Bedeutung sind
da wäre zunächst die in Emotionen in den
Energieträger der Zukunft in Wasserstoff
4 Milliarden Euro damit der Hochlauf der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft und der
dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft
passieren kann wir investieren wir
investieren 19 Milliarden Euro in die
Energieeffizienz im Gebäudebereich und
stellen sicher dass dort klimaneutrales
heizen für jeden Geldbeutel möglich ist
wir haben an dieser Stelle Maßnahmen
drinnen um die kleinen mittelständischen
Unternehmen das Handwerk zu unterstützen
knapp eine Milliarde Euro sind zur
Verfügung für Forschung und Entwicklung
und Innovation und wenn wir an die
Bekämpfung der Strukturschwäche denken
dann denke ich an die GAW die gerade
auch im Osten wertvolle Arbeit leistet
dieser Ansatz ist sogar auf 680
Millionen erhöht worden das sind alles
Maßnahmen die zeigen dass wir in dieser
Krise mit finanziellen Möglichkeiten
gegensteuern und bessere Voraussetzungen
für die Erholung der Konjunktur zu
leisten
ergänzen ergänzend ist und muss erwähnt
werden dass wir mit dem
wachstumschancengesetz steuerliche
Entlastungen in Höhe von 7 Milliarden
Euro auf den Weg bringen und hier ist
natürlich dann mal der Vermerk wichtig
dass dort die Länder mitziehen müssen
ich gehe davon aus dass an dieser Stelle
also auch die Einsicht dazu da ist und
das kam mir also in den letzten zwei
Tagen auch zur Sprache
bürokratieentlastung ist wichtig
insofern ist das was wir da geplant
haben auch begleitet von 2 Milliarden
Euro für die Wirtschaft etwas was hier
komplett unter den Tisch fällt was aber
in der Haushaltsplanung so weiter drin
steckt ich komme zum Schluss diese
Koalition zeigt erneut dass wir Krise
gut managen können dass wir in dieser
Krise nicht nur in der Lage sind Weichen
zu stellen sondern auch die
Herausforderungen der Zukunft zu
begegnen und das ist mir auch ganz
wichtig wir stellen dabei sicher dass
niemand unter die Räder kommt und das
niemand zu Herz wie sie das ja
vorgestern gefordert haben das ist an
dieser Stelle dazu kommt den Sozialstaat
zu rasieren das ist nicht unser Ziel und
dieses diesen Ansprüchen über diese
Haushalt gerecht
[Applaus]
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Wolfgang
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Politik
dieser Regierung führt in die Verarmung
die Industrialisierung
Einbruch des Lebensstandards der Bürger
Ruin der Staatsfinanzen lange ist es her
dass ein herausragender
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler wie Ludwig
Erhard das Wirtschaftsministerium
geführt hat nun erzählt uns hier ein
Kinderbuchautor Geschichten über die
Schuld anderer und verbreitet Panik vor
der Zukunft
welche Vermessenheit ist es zu glauben
dass das kleine Deutschland das
Weltklima retten könnte dabei ist es
nicht einmal bewiesen dass der Mensch
den Einfluss auf das Klima hat den Sie
hier immer beschweren den Preis dafür
zahlen aber die Menschen in Deutschland
immer weniger Bürger verstehen ihre
Politik Herbeck sie reden dauernd über
CO2 und nehmen zugleich unserem Land mit
der Kernkraft eine zuverlässige günstige
und CO2 freie Energiequelle weg
wer so handelt hat jedes moralische
Recht verloren den Menschen ihre Energie
fürs Heizen fahren und produzieren zu
verbieten
alleine ihr heizverbotsgesetz wird
unvorstellbare
2500 Milliarden Euro kosten das teuerste
Gesetz dieses Jahr 1000
das kommende verbrennerverbot trifft die
deutsche Autoindustrie ins Mark ihre
Energiepolitik sorgt für die höchsten
Strompreise der Welt und jetzt wollen
sie auch noch 30 Milliarden Subventionen
für einen industriestrompreis das ist
der Gipfel der politischen Quacksalberei
erst setzen sie Deutschland mit ihrer
Energiewende auf eine radikale Diät wenn
unser Land davon schwer krank wird
zücken sie eine steuergeldspritze jeder
vernünftige Arzt würde wie wir von der
AFD natürlich die die jetzt absetzen
Schluss also mit der gescheiterten
Energiewende fahren wir schnellstmöglich
die Kernkraftwerke wieder hoch auch
meine bayerische Heimat braucht dringend
verlässliche Energie
auf die Abholzung von Wäldern für
hässliche riesige Rotoren können wir
gerne verzichten
jetzt soll Wasserstoff ihre Energiewende
retten mit immer neuen Subventionen
bezahlen Sie Projekte die sonst keiner
macht weil sie sich einfach nicht lohnen
das Geld stammt aus dem sogenannten
Klima- und transformationsfonds dem
Milliardengrab für grüne Ideologie
bezahlen müssen ist die Bürger mit immer
höheren co2-abgaben auf Schmidt
heizstoffe und alles was mit Gas und Öl
produziert
das Versprechen der Ampel den Menschen
dieses Geld zurückzugeben ist nicht
eingelöst und es wird sich kaum ändern
denn sie werfen ist ja sofort wieder
hinaus
ihre Energiewende ruiniert die
Staatsfinanzen denken Sie nur an die
Energie-
[Applaus]
vom drohenden Absturz des
Lebensstandards in Deutschland müssen
Sie als sein oberster Verursacher wohl
ablenken warum sonst basteln Sie Herr
Habeck an jetzt an sogenannten neuen
Berechnungsmethoden bei der
wohlstandsmessung harte Fakten wie das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt das ausgerechnet in
Deutschland singt stören da natürlich
wir von der afd-fraktion werden ihre
schlechten Zahlen aber täglich auf den
Tisch legen
für Deutschland wäre es gut wenn Sie
besser heute als morgen den Hund nehmen
[Applaus]
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Carsten klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die deutsche
Wirtschaftsleistung der Wohlstand in
Deutschland das ist kein Dauerauftrag
der uns monatlich automatisch überwiesen
wird sondern dieser Wohlstand der muss
von den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern hier
hart erwirtschaftet werden und bevor wir
ihn nicht erwirtschaftet haben können
wir auch nicht ans Verteilen gehen und
die deutsche Wirtschaft das sind die
ArbeitnehmerInnen und Arbeitgeber das
sind die Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber und das sind die
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland die diesen
Wohlstand erwirtschaften und diese
Wirtschaft ist mit großen
Herausforderungen aktuell konfrontiert
die im Ergebnis dazu führen dass die
deutsche Wirtschaft schrumpft eine
dieser Herausforderungen Minister sie
haben das angesprochen resultieren aus
der hohen Inflationsrate Inflation sorgt
für Unsicherheit bei den Betrieben bei
der Preisgestaltung aber die Inflation
hat natürlich mehrere Gründe ein großer
Grund sind natürlich die gestiegenden
Energiepreise aber wir hatten schon vor
der Energiekrise vor dem
kinderrechtswidrigen Einmarsch von
vadimir Putin in der Ukraine eine viel
zu hohe Inflationsrate gegen die die EZB
leider viel zu spät agiert hat und
deshalb ist es richtig wenn wir in der
Politik entschieden haben dass wir die
expansive
Ausgabenpolitik der coronazeit beenden
dass wir die Schuldenbremse wieder
einhalten das ist ein wichtiger Beitrag
um diese Inflation zu bekämpfen
aber in der Lage in der sich die
deutsche Wirtschaft befindet muss man
natürlich auch Wachstumsimpulse senden
und das tut diese Bundesregierung mit
dem wachstumsschancengesetz der Kollege
Junge ist schon darauf eingegangen 7
Milliarden Euro Entlastungsvolumen und
lieber Herr Merz das wird der
lackmusstest für Sie sie haben ja am
Mittwoch gestern eine große Ankündigung
gemacht wie sie sich Entlastungen in
diesem Land vorstellen und deshalb
werden wir sehr genau hinschauen wie sie
ihre Ministerpräsidenten der Union dazu
bringen diesen wachstumsschancengesetz
zu zustimmen da können Sie hier in
Berlin anfangen bei ihrem Regierenden
Bürgermeister der hat ja schon erklärt
dass er dieses wachstumschancengesetz
ablehnt also er will diese Impulse für
die deutsche Wirtschaft nicht aussenden
und daran werden wir Sie natürlich
messen
und der zweite Baustein Herr Minister
sie sind auch darauf eingegangen ist
natürlich der Bürokratieabbau und da bin
ich Justizminister Marco Buschmann sehr
dankbar dass er eine Initiative
gestartet hat die die deutsche
Wirtschaft um 2,3 Milliarden Euro an
Bürokratie Lasten entlasten wird und da
Liebe Union ein kleineren schönen Gruß
an sie die letzte große Initiative von
ihnen also groß muss man ja relativ in
relative Anführungszeichen setzen waren
1,1 Milliarden Euro das ist ziemlich
lange her und deshalb glaube ich sollten
Sie kleinere Brötchen backen wenn sie
Bewertungen unseres Bürokratie erbaus
vornehmen
keine Frage eine große Herausforderung
sind die enorm hohen Energiepreise aber
die Erneuerungen Energiepreise sind auch
nicht erst seit einem Jahr so hoch
Deutschland hat schon seit mehreren
Jahren die höchsten Energiepreise im
internationalen europäischen Vergleich
es gibt unzählige Berichte des
Bundesrechnungshof noch aus Zeiten des
CDU Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier
wie grotten schlecht die Energiewende
gemanagt wird und diese hohen
Energiepreise sind ein großes Problem
für die deutsche Industrie wir haben
aber auch als Politik in
Mehrheitsentscheidung dafür gesorgt dass
das Angebot drastisch eingeschränkt wird
Atomausstieg Kohleausstieg alles
beschlossen unter der Unionsführung in
im übrigen wir haben uns in eine sehr
trügerische und beklemmende Abhängigkeit
beim großen Energieträger Gas gegeben
auch das in den letzten 16 Jahren leider
Erfolg da kann ich sie nicht rauslassen
und wir sind viel zu langsam
eingestiegen in die Alternativen wenn es
um Netzausbau gehen oder regenerative
Energie und das ist auf der
Regierungsbank damals
mindestens eins Regierungspartner
nämlich die CSU die nicht nur aktiv
diese Sachen bekämpft hat sondern in
Bayern dafür gesorgt hat dass keine
Windkraft ausgebaut worden ist dass kein
Netzausbau stattgefunden hat sie tragen
große Verantwortung für diese
Energiekrise und deshalb ist es richtig
wenn der Bundeskanzler gestern
formuliert hat dass er von Ihnen
erwartet dass sie sich bei der Lösung
auch einbringen wir als Ampel haben und
die Kollegium ist darauf eingegangen
auch Sie Herr Minister ein großes Paket
geschnürt um gegen diese hohe
Energiepreise noch anzukämpfen mit der
Gas und strompreisbremse mit der
Verlängerung des Spitzenausgleich mit
der Abschaffung des ehe der eg-umlage
für die Haushalte das waren große
Kraftakte aber wir werden da nicht
stehen bleiben wir müssen den Anteil der
staatlichen Abgaben an den Strompreis
weiter sinken und deshalb müssen wir die
Stromsteuer senken
letztlich darf es aber nicht dazu führen
dass wir in Dauer Subventionen
einsteigen denn die Marktkräfte die
Preismechanismen müssen auch weiter
wirken die Politik kann bei den großen
Veränderungen die international
stattfinden natürlich begleiten und
unterstützen aber letztendlich sind die
Unternehmen die Akteure und deshalb
dürfen wir dürfen wir der deutschen
Wirtschaft auch diesen wichtigen
informationspolen der Preise nicht auf
Dauer wegnehmen ich freue mich auf die
Haushaltsberatung Herr Minister wir
werden über viele Prioritätensetzungen
sicher noch mal intensiv diskutieren
beim Fachkräftemangel auch beim Thema
Raumfahrt zum Beispiel das wird eine
spannende Zeit aber ich denke wir werden
alle gemeinsam dann zu einer guten
Lösung kommen und weitere
Wachstumsimpulse für unsere deutsche
Wirtschaft Aussehen vielen Dank für Ihre
aufmerksam
keit nächster
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland ist die einzige große
Volkswirtschaft die schrumpft in dieser
Situation liegt die ampelkondition die
ein kürzungshaushalt vorn was für eine
Realitätsverweigerung
die Regierung
gefällt damit Wohlstand und
Arbeitsplätze waren das Deutsche
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung der
Entwurf sei ökonomisch unklug unsozial
und unstrategisch das sehen wir genauso
meine Damen und Herren
ein stadtverstärkt in die Zukunft zu
investieren und die Laden wieder aus der
Krise rauszuziehen fahren Sie ihn noch
dicker rein und machen damit das Land
und die Leute zu Absteigern das ist die
völlig falsche Richtung und das führt
natürlich dann immer größeren
Unzufriedenheit über diese Regierung da
dürfen sie sich überhaupt nicht darüber
wundern meine Damen und Herren
die Politik der Bundesregierung führt zu
einer gigantischen Umverteilung von
Unten wo die normalen Bürgern nach oben
die drei großen Stromkonzerne haben im
letzten Jahr Profite von 17,6 Milliarden
Euro kassiert während normale Bürger und
Betriebe Höchstpreise Zahlen verdienen
sich diese Kunst seine dumme und dämlich
dann muss endlich Schluss sein meine
Damen und Herren
da haben wir nicht vergessen da haben
wir nicht vergessen das Kanzler Scholz
und Minister Habig versprochen hatten
von diesem krisengewinn viele Milliarden
übergewinne abschöpfen zu wollen um die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu entlasten aber
das Gesetz kam so spät es galt so kurz
und es war so schlecht dass statt der
vielen Milliarden nicht mal eine halbe
zusammenkam das lässt sich mit
Unfähigkeit nicht mehr erklären das war
Vorsatz die ampelkondition ist
Schutzmacht der Milliardäre und
Krisengewinner
anstatt die teuerungsstelle zu stoppen
und Menschen mit kleinen mittleren
Einkommen zu entlasten macht die Ampel
das Leben der Leute noch teurer
die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas und auf
Fernwärme steigt zum ersten Januar 24
und 12%. das selbe Geld für die
Gastronomie 12% teurer die Eltern müssen
dann mehr fürs Kita und Schulen Essen
bezahlen das ist unsere Politik wir
fordern Sie auf diese Teuerung zu
stoppen meine Damen und Herren
sie hatten dann versprochen die Bürger
zu entlasten mit dem Klimagerät aber es
wird verschleppt mindestens bei 2026 das
hält sie jetzt aber nicht davon ab die
CO2-Preise fürs Tanken und fürs Heizen
zu erhöhen das kostet die Bevölkerung
2,3 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr ohne
Ausgleich durch einen Klimagerät es ist
eine gigantische Belastung für die große
Märkte Bevölkerung die er eben kleine
und mittlere Einkommen hat das ist keine
soziale Politik das ist keine Politik
für Klimaschutz Herr Habicht das ist
Politik gegen die mehr zu Bevölkerung
wir brauchen zum Land soziale
Gerechtigkeit und sie machen genau das
Gegenteil
sich die grüne teile ich das Wort Felix
frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
gerade einer Rede des Abgeordneten Jens
Spahn bei gewohnt die formal glaube ich
eine Antwort auf die Rede des
Wirtschaftsministers sein sollte aber
inhaltlich nicht viel damit zu tun hat
und Herr Spanisch weiß ja die Botschaft
entsteht beim Empfänger aber das ändert
nichts daran dass der Empfänger
vielleicht zuhören müsste um zu gucken
ob die vorbereitete Rede noch passt
[Applaus]
gestern habe ich ihrer Rede zugehört und
ich verstehe ja dass sie nervös sind ich
verstehe dass sie nervös sind das läuft
ja alles auch nicht ganz gut aber
glauben Sie wirklich dass es das beste
Konzept ist die eigene Schwäche dadurch
ausgleichen zu wollen dass man dieses
Land dass man diesen Wirtschaftsstandort
diesen Industriestandort schlechter
redet als er ist glauben Sie dass das
die Verantwortung einer Opposition in
einer ja tatsächlich herausfordernden
Situation gerecht wird dieses Land
schlecht zu reden und überall in die
Welt hinaus zu posaunen investiert nicht
in Deutschland hier liegt was im Argen
glauben Sie dass das ihrer Verantwortung
gerecht wird ich meine das können sie
besser und als ich gestern das gehört
habe ist mir ist eine Liedzeile
eingefallen von Rio Reiser an früher ist
Werk da sagt er zum schluckt sie runter
eure alten Phrasen und fasst euch
endlich mal an die eigene Nasen und wie
ist der Zufall so will meine Damen und
Herren heißt dieses Lied bitte böser
Friederich Mensch sachen gibt's in der
Welt
dieser Wirtschaftsstandort meine Damen
und Herren ist und er bleibt stark das
sehen wir daran dass bis zu 80
Milliarden Auslandsinvestitionen jetzt
nach Deutschland kommen intel ist ja nur
das prominenteste Beispiel dafür und was
sagt Intel warum sie hier hingehen weil
der Wirtschaftsstandort stark ist weil
wir ein starkes Ausbildungssystem haben
weil wir jetzt auch dafür sorgen gegen
ihren Widerstand ein Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz beschlossen haben
dass die Fachkräfte politisch neu ist
die wir seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten
kämpfen endlich anzugehen und was sagt
Insel warum sie nach Deutschland kommen
aber eben nach Magdeburg wegen der
erneuerbaren Energien weil wir endlich
dazu kommen die auszubauen und deswegen
muss man doch sagen meine Damen und
Herren
wenn es eine politische Kraft in diesem
Land gibt die ein echtes die
undezialisierungsrisiko ist dann ist es
doch die CSU in Bayern die den
Netzausbau verschleppt hat die den
erneuerbaren Energien blockiert hat wo
immer sie konnte Markus Schröder ja fast
höchstpersönlich sich auf die Felder
geklebt hat damit hier kein Stromnetz
ausgebaut wird Bayern
ein Land Bayern ein Land in dem
17-Jährige die sich auf die Straße
kleben weil sich so um ihre Zukunft
machen präventiv in den Knast gesperrt
werden und 17-Jährige die mit
vernichtungs- und vergasungsphantasien
durch die Schule laufen ein würdiger
Ministerpräsidenten Stellvertreter für
Markus Söder sind dieses Land braucht
einen Wechsel und haben jetzt zum Glück
demnächst die bayerischen Bayern die
Gelegenheit zu tun
und sehr sparen sie haben ja ein
spannendes Brief von den 70ern 80ern den
besten Hits von heute noch mal versucht
aufzulegen aber ehrlich gesagt das was
sie da versuchen ist doch auf das
Erfolgsmodell von Joe Biden mit den
Rezepten von Ronald Reagan zu reagieren
kommen Sie doch an in den 20er Jahren
dieses Jahrhunderts gehen sie raus aus
den 80er Jahren Berlin Kreuzberg auch
nicht mehr so gefährlich für sie
das was ansteht das was ansteht ist
jetzt auf die Impulse aus den USA auf
den Inflation reduct mit einer aktiven
Politik zu reagieren eine aktiven
Industriepolitik die
Wertschöpfungsketten hält die dieses
Land stark gemacht haben Stahl Chemie
Aluminium all diese dazu braucht es auch
Dinge wie ein industriestrompreis des
mag nicht die reine marktwirtschaftliche
ordnungspolitische Lehre sein aber was
ist eine pragmatische Antwort auf die
Situation
ganz eindeutig dass sie sich so deutlich
unter Robert haben in dieser Frage
stellen vielen Dank dafür vielen Dank
meine Damen und Herren für das was an
der nächsten Wochen noch ansteht ein
guter Beratung ich freue mich drauf
und für die Unionsfraktion hat nur das
Wort die Kollegin Julia Klöckner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte
frau Präsidentin
Herr Bundeswirtschaftsminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr reinhartag
ihre Stand-Up-Comedy hier eben war ja
echt goldig geil ich meine angesichts
angesichts der Umfragewerte der Grünen
in Bayern wer ist da schon ein bisschen
anders unterwegs und sie werfen der CSU
vor sie würde den Industriestandort
Deutschland gefährden des CSU geführte
Bundesland Bayern finanziert Länder mit
wo sie in der Regierung sind weil sie es
nicht hinkriegen das muss man einfach
sich mal angucken
und ein zweiter Punkt Stichwort
erneuerbare Energien schauen wir uns den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien an es
gibt kein Bundesland das so weit vorne
liegt wie Bayern sie sind spitze in der
Biomasse Spitze in der Wasserkraft
Spitze im Solar und sie sagen dass es
Comedy das Problem dieser ampelregierung
ist dass sie schon scheitert wenn sie
Bestandsaufnahme macht ihre
Bestandsaufnahme ist falsch deshalb sind
auch ihre folgeschlüsse ebenfalls die
Kollegin Glöckner erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus dem Rhein der Grünen
sehr
gerne vielen Dank Frau Kollegin dass sie
die Zwischenfrage zulassen sie hatten
gerade gesagt dass David die Grünen
regieren der Netzausbau und der
Ausbildung Erneuerbaren nicht so
funktioniert ist ihnen ist und da wo die
CSU CDU regiert das habe ich so gehört
sie hören ihrer Kollegin nicht zu sie
haben was ganz anderes für spannend also
sie haben das gerade gesagt es ihnen
bewusst dass ihm jetzt die Beispiele an
den beiden Enden der Republik zu nehmen
Bayern wo ja auch bald gewählt wird
Schleswig-Holstein wo Minister habe ich
lange Verantwortung getragen hat noch
jetzt die Grünen noch Verantwortung
tragen der Netzausbau hervorragend
funktioniert hat die Stromleitungen die
Stromleitung auch auf 380 kV den Strom
schon transportieren weil die einfach
fertig sind wenn der Netzausbau und
Bayern nicht vorankommt dass der Ausbau
der Wind Energie in Schleswig-Holstein
ganz vorne dabei ist genauso wie in
anderen Ländern wo grüne mit regieren
wissen Sie eigentlich wie viele nämlich
sehr sehr wenige Anträge auf
Windenergieanlage in Bayern gestellt
sind die sagen sie haben Solar wissen
Sie eigentlich dass sie auch im Winter
Strom brauchen dass sie Wind und solange
brauchen das sind nicht reicht und
deswegen frage ich sie wie soll der
Wirtschaftsstandort Bayern funktionieren
wenn die erneuerbaren Energien
durchgebremst sind wenn im Winter eben
nicht die Windenergie liefert und haben
sie irgendein Argument das widerlegt
dass die CDU und die CSU insbesondere in
Bayern Energie nicht vorangebracht haben
Frau Kollegin ich freue mich dass Ihnen
jetzt Zeit für eine Rede gegeben hat die
ihren ihre Fraktion ihnen nicht
ermöglicht hat um kurz zu sagen sie
haben mir gerade etwas unterstellt an
Zitat was ich gar nicht gesagt habe und
deshalb noch einmal um es sehr deutlich
zu machen
ihr vor oder ihr Kollege aus der
Fraktion sagte eben die CSU würde den
Wirtschaftsstandort Bayern gefährden ich
weiß gar nicht wo ihre Analysedaten
herkommen die Lokomotive die
Wirtschaftslokomotive in Deutschland ist
Bayern der zweite Punkt ist
das Thema das Thema Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien wir haben eine
Anfrage an die Bundesregierung gestellt
also die aktuelle Bundesregierung also
wo sie mit Teil sind ihre Partei und
dann gab es eine Antwort auf die Anfrage
wo der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
vorne liegt und ihr berufen uns auf die
Antwort der Bundesregierung und die sagt
Bayern ist vorne bei Solar bei
Wasserkraft bei Biomasse ist vorne beim
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien und
jetzt haben sie mir ein Stichwort
gegeben mit den Grünen wo sie in der
Regierung sind ich komme aus
Rheinland-Pfalz da sind die Grünen mit
drin da muss ich Ihnen sagen was das
Thema Windkraft angeht haben sie ja
gerade so eine halbe Rüge auch bekommen
da hat ihre Partei nicht viel erreicht
und dann gehen wir mal Baden-Württemberg
da sind die Grünen sogar in der
Staatskanzlei da ist man auch nicht weit
vorne bei der Windkraft also insofern
meine ich wäre schon ganz gut weg mit
der Ideologie weg mit den
gesinnungsschubladen hin zu den Fakten
hat die richtige Analyse hat dann kann
man auch das richtige Rezept um
gegenzusteuern auch anwenden und das
würde ich Ihnen raten
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
habe mir mal die Homepage des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers angeschaut da
ist ein schönes Zitat zugegeben klingt
gut
Zitat Politik ist die Hinwendung zur
Welt
wir würden uns ja schon
freuen darüber wenn ihre Politik eine
Hinwendung zu Deutschland und zur
Wirtschaft wäre denn das ist ihre
Aufgabe
Vizekanzler wir fragen uns wo bleibt
eigentlich die Stimme der Wirtschaft in
dieser Bundesregierung noch kurz vor der
Sommerpause in der regierungsbefragung
hier Bundeskanzler wurde das alles als
falsche Fakten abgetan Inflation
eine Rezession und im übrigen Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sie sprachen
eben von einem
konjunkturellen delle alle
Wirtschaftsinstitute alle experten
sprechen von einer tiefgreifenden
Rezession das ist so ähnlich wie mit dem
Abschalten der Kernkraft sie haben den
Eindruck alle anderen sind die
Geisterfahrer nur sie liegen richtig ich
würde sagen man müsste mal die
Perspektive wechseln weil hier geht es
um den Standort Deutschland und nicht um
ihre parteitagsprogramm
und sie sprachen davon dass ein grün
Wirtschaftswunder uns
bevorstehen würde wie in den 1950er
1960er Jahren also ein
Geschichtsvergessenheit und
Überheblichkeit mangels hier jetzt nicht
gerade bei Ihnen und wir haben jetzt
heute sie sprachen davon man muss aus
Fehlern lernen das finde ich gut und
auch richtig und man muss auch Fehler
eingestehen finde ich auch gut und
richtig aber dass sie immer diejenigen
beschimpfen die auf diese Fehler schon
frühzeitig hingewiesen haben und wir
hätten uns echt Zeit sparen können
Verunsicherung der Leute sparen können
und das Abwandern der Unternehmen wenn
sie von gutem Export sprechen zurzeit
exportieren wir gute Unternehmen ins
Ausland aber nicht Produkte denn made in
Germany ist leider aufgrund der hohen
Kosten die wir haben nicht mehr so
gefordert im Inland wie im Ausland wie
es eigentlich sein sollte und was tun
sie
Herr Wirtschaftsminister
zur Eröffnung der IAA haben sie
verkündet also die Automobilbauer
müssten sich jetzt mal anstrengen die
müssen dafür sorgen dass dieser
Wirtschaftsstandort wettbewerbsfähig sei
da haben sie grundlegend etwas falsch
verstanden die Automobilbauer sind dafür
zuständig dass sie gute Autos bauen
wettbewerbsfähige Autos bauen aber sie
sind zuständig dass dieser
standortwettbewerbsfähig ist das ist
ihre Aufgabe und nicht die Aufgabe der
Industrie und der Unternehmen wie gesagt
sie scheitern bereits an der
Bestandsaufnahme und anders kann man
sich auch gar nicht erklären warum sie
die Mittel für digitale Technologie und
Forschung hier kürzen sie kürzen für die
berufliche Bildung für den Mittelstand
für die Fachkräfte Sicherung das ist
ihre Schönheit sie sagen wir reden den
Standort schlecht dieses Geleier im
übrigen auch diese 16 Jahre das Argument
das hat sich schon so abgenutzt also
wenn sie wirklich in nicht eingehen
wollen als die Regierung der
Deindustrialisierung und der Rezession
dann wäre es gut wenn sie meinen Update
vornehmen würden was die Fakten auch
angeht und deshalb sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Auftrag zurückgänge bei uns
in der Industrie liegen bei 12 Prozent
und diese Zahl sagt sehr viel aus was
der Wirtschaft in Zukunft drohen wird
und das macht uns Sorge wir haben heute
morgen die Zahl bekommen dass die
Produktion zurückgänge bei etwa zwei
Prozent liegen und das addiert ist ein
Zustand wo sie einberufen müssen einen
Krisengipfel für die Wirtschaft Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister zusammen mit
dem Bundeskanzler und bitte mit dem
gesamten Kabinett warum damit sie alle
an einem Strang ziehen sie machen einen
Pakt für Deutschland es wäre gut wenn
sie mal packt für ihre eigene Regierung
machen würden es hat ein Grund warum sie
heute nicht über den industriestrompreis
gesprochen haben weil sie hier sehr sehr
unterschiedliche Meinungen haben
inklusive Kanzler und inklusive seiner
Fraktion und deshalb sagen wir sehr klar
der Preis muss runter ja er hat doch was
präsentiert er denn zuerst hat er gesagt
ganz am Anfang 13 Cent dann war er
plötzlich bei 6 entdeckt der Kanzler war
mal für vier Cent jetzt ist er gegen
alles die Fraktion der SPD ist für den
industriestrompreis ich sage sehr klar
wer zuerst des Angebots der
energieverknappt selbst solche
politische Entscheidung den Preis
hochtreibt das dann wieder runter
subventionieren will den
Spitzenausgleich streicht aber die
Stromsteuer oben lässt Leute macht doch
meinen gescheites Konzept bevor er an
die Öffentlichkeit geht und dann
unterstützen bei euch auch
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun das Wort
Verena Huberts
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen jeder
Spitzensportler weiß es ist schwieriger
vorne zu bleiben als nach vorne zu
kommen und das beschreibt auch ein
bisschen die Herausforderungen die wir
gerade in unserer Wirtschaft haben wir
sind vorne wir sind die stärkste
Volkswirtschaft Europas aber damit das
so bleibt stehen wir nicht hier und
beschreiben wie Frau Klöckner irgendeine
Welt sondern
wir und wir investieren mehr als wir es
in den vergangenen Jahren getan haben
über 100 Milliarden Euro in die
wirtschaftliche Stärke unseres Landes
und natürlich sind wir nicht alleine auf
der Welt wir sind eine starke
Exportnation und wenn der Wind auf den
sehen ein bisschen rauer wird dann
merken wir natürlich auch wenn es in
Asien gerade auch mal zurückkommen aber
Herr Spahn sie haben gefragt in welcher
Welt leben wir denn wenn wir jetzt in
Deutschland Pack machen sie sagen machen
Sie doch mal was das ist jetzt auch
nicht richtig ich sage stehen sie doch
mal bitte nicht auf der Bremse sondern
machen Sie doch mal gefälligst mit in
diesem Land
wir brauchen Tempo statt Stillstand das
hat gestern der Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz hier gut gesagt endlich mal weg
von Funklöchern endlich mal weg von
Meter langen Aktenbergen für
Genehmigungsverfahren wir müssen
schneller werden und dafür brauchen wir
auch alle in diesem Land die eben
mitmachen wir haben 16 Bundesländer wir
brauchen die Gesellschaft wir brauchen
die Wirtschaft die Landrätinnen und
Landräte die Bürgermeisterinnen und
Bürgermeister denn wir haben doch
lange gegründe gefunden warum es nicht
geht wir brauchen jetzt mal Wege für
mehr Mut für mehr Tempo und für mehr
Wirtschaftswachstum
und wenn wir einen Blick auf die
Wirtschaft in die Wirtschaft werfen ich
bin ständig mit Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmern im Austausch dann sind das
natürlich vielfältige strukturelle
Probleme der Fachkräftemangel deswegen
haben wir ein modernes
einwanderungssystem nach kanadischen
Vorbild geschaffen das Potenziale mit
Punkten bewertet und nicht die
Abschlüsse wir brauchen Anreize für
Innovationen für Investitionen
wachstumschancengesetz bietet jede Menge
mit dem zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz
werden wir dafür sorgen dass auch der
Startup Standort nach vorne kommt und da
werden über 32 Milliarden in die Hand
genommen und mobilisiert
und natürlich
machen wir uns nichts vor das große
Problem sind die hohen Energiepreise in
unserem Land mein Kollege Matthias
Mirsch wird gleich noch mal ausführen wo
wir da auch noch mal Gas geben müssen
damit das Angebot mehr wird aber es ist
doch auch so dass wir uns überlegen
müssen wie und was wir mit aktiver
Wirtschaftspolitik tun deswegen hat sich
meine Fraktion die SPD für einen
industriestrompreis ausgesprochen als
Brücke die Brücke die dahin geht bis wir
genug erneuerbare bis wir genug günstige
Stromangebote in diesem Land haben
wir müssen doch die Kunststoffindustrie
in unserem Land halten das ist Chemie
das ist Stahl das ist Kupfer denn ohne
die kein Windrad kein Auto und keine
Halbleiter und deswegen ist es so
wichtig aber und da möchte ich jetzt ja
auch nichts verhehlen wir sind in dieser
Koalition gerade dabei die richtige
Antwort auf diese Frage zu finden weil
wir wollen nicht klein gegen Groß
ausspielen wir brauchen auch was für den
Mittelstand da müssen wir entlassen
alles gut aber wenn wir eins gezeigt
haben als Ampel ist dass wir in der Lage
sind auf große auf sehr komplexe Fragen
Herausforderungen auch Lösungen zu
finden und das wird uns auch wieder
diesmal gelingen und deswegen lade ich
Sie alle ein zum Mitmachen nicht zum
lamentieren denn dieses Land braucht
Fortschritt dieses Land braucht Tempo es
braucht Mut und keinen Stillstand
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
live Erik Holm
sehr geehrte Bürger frau Präsidentin
meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland steckt in ernsten
wirtschaftlichen Schwierigkeiten und von
Ihnen Herr Minister haben wir dazu heute
nur heiße Luft in einer lieblosen Rede
bekommen das wird im Ernst der Lage
nicht gerecht
wir sehen es doch anhand der Daten wir
sind in einer Rezession in anderen
Ländern sieht es viel viel besser aus
unsere Unternehmen große Unternehmen
wandern ins Ausland ab Kapital wird mehr
im Ausland investiert als im Inland die
Arbeitslosigkeit steigt der
konsumschwäche weil die Teuerung zu groß
ist die Menschen wissen nicht mehr wie
sie über den Monat kommen sollen und
hier kommen keine Antworten auf diese
Situation ihre Antwort ist weiterhin wir
machen weiter wie bisher der
heizungshammer muss durchgedrückt werden
nein diese Regierung hat den Schuss
nicht gehört und deswegen stehen sie im
Moment auch in den Umfragen da wo sie
hingehören die Bürger haben genug von
ihrem ideologischen mords machen sie den
Weg frei für Neuwahlen
jeder sieht es Deutschland ist nicht
mehr attraktiv jedenfalls nicht als
Wirtschaftsstandort es ist eine
bürokratische Wüste die Abgabenlast ist
zu hoch und die Politik setzt Milliarden
um Milliarden in den Sand mit einer
Energiepolitik über die der Rest der
Welt nur den Kopf schüttelt es passt
vorne und hinten einfach nicht zusammen
was sie tun ein ampelparadoxon jagt das
nächste die Apfel will angeblich
günstigen Strom und schaltet die
Kernkraftwerke ab die Ampel will
angeblich Bürokratie abbauen und schafft
ein bürokratisches monstrumen nach dem
nächsten sicherheitshalle die Abwehr
angeblich die Inflation drücken und
erhöht schon wieder die CO2-Abgabe sie
ziehen sie sogar noch vor auf den
Jahreswechsel das heißt die Spritpreise
werden zum Jahreswechsel schon wieder
steigen die Ampel für den
Arbeitskräftemangel beheben und erhöht
das Bürgergeld arbeiten gehen lohnt sich
für viele kaum noch wer so Politik macht
der muss sich nicht wundern dass gut
qualifizierte Leute ja für Jahr das weit
und ins Auslands Auslands gehen es sind
fast 100.000 netto netto pro Jahr
stattdessen kommen ungesteuert Migranten
aus aller Welt ins Land meistens
unqualifiziert und das einzige zu nutzen
was bei uns noch attraktiv ist nämlich
das Sozialsystem für alle und jeden aber
so darf es nicht weiterlaufen deswegen
sagen wir das werden wir in einer
Regierung ändern weil es geändert werden
muss und es braucht ein wirtschaftliches
Sofortprogramm wir haben es mit unserem
zehn Punkte Programm vorgelegt wir
müssen runter mit den Energiepreisen und
zwar für alle deswegen sagen wir
Stromsteuer aufs Minimum Energiesteuer
aufs Minimum CO2-Abgabe nicht erhöhen
sondern abschaffen und das
Energieangebot muss endlich ausgebaut
werden wir sind mittlerweile Strom
Importeur geworden dank ihrer
abenteuerlichen Politik mehr Strom
Angebot bedeutet Versorgungssicherheit
und Sinken der Preise und das hat eine
Studie gezeigt wir könnten acht
Kernkraftwerke
wieder ans Netz nehmen tun wir endlich
die Kernkraft ist eben kein totes Pferd
wie der Kanzleramt um uns herum geht
sehr quicklebendig zu anderen Länder
bauen neue Kraftwerke Schweden
Frankreich die Niederlande Polen alle
gehen einen anderen vernünftigeren Weg
den müssen wir auch gehen nein meine
Damen und Herren das einzige ich sag mal
mindestens klappt wie gefährlich ist die
Ampel und diesen alten Klepper den
müssen wir jetzt dringend auf den
Gnadenhof schicken danke schön
für die FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort
Reinhard Huben
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
also es ist ja eben vorgeworfen worden
wir hätten schon Probleme bei der
Bestandsaufnahme der wirtschaftlichen
Situation in Deutschland vor Klöckner
ich stelle fest sie haben schon ein
Problem bei der Bestandsaufnahme der
Rede von Robert Habeck denn er hat
natürlich über den industriestrompreis
gesprochen zweitens bei ihrer
Bestandsaufnahme muss ich sagen sie
haben nach der Stimme der Regierung für
die Wirtschaft
gefragt kann ich Ihnen beantworten
am Dienstag hat Christian Lindner darauf
geantwortet die FDP ist die Bastion der
finanzpolitischen Zuverlässigkeit Olaf
Scholz hat gesprochen über die
Wirtschaft in einem weiten Bogen und
Robert Habeck hat heute zum Thema
Wirtschaft gesprochen sie sollten
vielleicht ein bisschen besser zuhören
dann würden sie vielleicht auch anders
argumentieren
denn meine Damen und Herren sie haben
uns vorgeworfen wir würden schon bei der
bestandsaufnahmeschaltern ich sage Ihnen
sie scheitern bei den Vorschlägen die
sie Einbringen von der Union da wird
also einerseits in Debatte geführt wir
wollen die Steuern erhöhen
und gleichzeitig spricht Herr Spahn
davon Menschen zu motivieren mehr zu
leisten das wird man bestimmt durch
Steuererhöhungen erreichen ja der
Vorsitzende des Haushaltsausschuss Herr
Braun sagt ja eigentlich brauchen die
Schuldenbremse nicht mehr merkwürdig
dann haben sie die unterschiedlichsten
Ideen Vorschläge der Entlastung und wenn
dann ihr Vorsitzender Friedrich Merz im
Deutschlandfunk gefragt wird ja sie
machen hier Vorschläge über einige
Milliarden Euro wie wollen Sie das den
finanzieren da sagt der also das ist
alles nicht entscheidend wir müssen nur
dafür sorgen dass jetzt die
Steuereinnahmen in Deutschland steigen
und die Sozialversicherungsbeiträge
erhöht werden und dort mehr Geld in die
Kasse kommt das meine Damen und Herren
von der Union wird der deutschen
Wirtschaft nicht helfen
auch wenn die Situation in Deutschland
sicherlich nicht einfach ist haben wir
hier mit einem Haushaltsvorschlag
vorliegen damit wir aus dem krisenmodus
herauskommen das werden wir in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen auch weiter
diskutieren und ich bin mir sicher dass
wir vernünftige Lösungen finden werden
und ja meine Damen und Herren natürlich
sympathisiert die FDP damit an der
stromsteuerschraube zu drehen nach unten
um eben nicht nur
2200 Unternehmen in Deutschland zu
entlasten sondern den Studenten die
Rentnerin den kleinen und Mittelständler
und die großen Betriebe das ist außerdem
auch möglich ohne irgendwelche Probleme
in Europa mit den Fragen von wer Hilfe
recht deswegen wenn wir finanzielle
Spielräume finden in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen machen wir uns stark für die
Senkung der Stromsteuer vielen Dank
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin ist sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren leider keine Zeit für
Tätigkeiten
deshalb gleich zum Thema als erstes
nehmen wir die wirtschaftlichen Probleme
ich habe den Eindruck dass diese
Regierung die eigentliche
wirtschaftliche Lage in dieser Republik
nicht mehr wahrnimmt
wenn die in der deutsche Industrie- und
Handel deutsche Industrie des
Handelskammer 3.500 Unternehmen befragt
und da kommen in 16 Prozent zu dem
Ergebnis dass sie
ihre Produktion in diesem Lande nicht
mehr halten können weil die
Energiepreise so hoch sind und sie
machen gleichzeitig nicht die geringste
Bemerkung dazu das ist die eigenen
Wirtschaftssanktionen sind die auch zu
diesen hohen Preisen geführt hat ja
das habe ich auch das habe ich erwartet
das habe ich aber wir sind klug und weil
sie haben es selbst entdeckt gell das
ist so ihre Politik wenn Sie schauen wie
die wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung in
Russland ist dann merken sie die am
Wachstum und wir was haben wir wir haben
ein negatives Wachstum wir Rauschen hier
in eine Rezession und sie sind nicht
bereit darüber nachzudenken dass die
Preisentwicklung natürlich was damit zu
tun hat dass sie das Angebot verknappt
haben und zwar durch die eigenen
Sanktionen deshalb mein erster Punkt
wenn wir das so weitermachen wenn Sie
das so weitermachen tragen Sie dazu bei
dieses Land wirklich einen Schritt
weiter zu ruinieren deshalb hoffe ich
sie können kommen dort zu einer
vernünftigen Einschätzung selbst Frau
Bär Bock hat ja inzwischen festgestellt
wie ein wundert das haut so nicht
richtig hin mit den Sanktionen dann
könnten Sie sich doch mal bei ihrer
Außenministerin informieren warum sie zu
dieser Einschätzung kommt und der zweite
Punkt wo sie vollkommen in der neben
liegen das ist ihre Klimapolitik wenn
man eine Klimapolitik macht so wie sie
das heizungsgesetz machen mit
Missachtung des Parlaments durch
Verfassungsgericht bestätigt wenn man
vorrügen gegen die Bürger ein
energy-türme bauen das halbe Land
rebelliert und wundert sich dass die
Leute dass sie von Klimaschutz abwenden
da wundert ich mich warum sie nicht
selbst zu der Erkenntnis kommen dass sie
im Klimaschutz genauso versagt haben wie
bei der Wirtschaftspolitik
und verbindest 90 die Grünen hat das
Wort dr Sandra detzer
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Damen und Herren der Chef der
größten Volkswirtschaft der Welt
US-Präsident Joe Biden hat in einer Rede
auf dem Punkt gebracht
i think Jobs wenn ich Klima höre denke
ich Jobs das ist Klimaschutz als
Innovationstreiber das ist die Leitlinie
der größten Volkswirtschaft der Welt und
genau diese Linie findet sich nun
endlich im Einzelplan 09 des
Wirtschaftsministeriums wieder
inzwischen Ökonomie und Ökologie gehört
kein oder
der Weg zum klimafreundlichen Wachstum
bückt enorme Potenziale für Wohlstand im
Einklang mit den planetaren Grenzen und
ja selbstverständlich sind da auch viel
Widerstände und Angst und nun kann man
natürlich versuchen aus dieser
Unsicherheit politisches Kapital zu
schlagen wie das die Union immer wieder
tut zeigt aber vor allen Dingen keine
Haltung sondern es zeigt die eigenen
Schwäche und ich habe mich schon ein
bisschen gewundert über den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden März der vor allen
Dingen angekündigt hat alle
Entscheidungen der Ampel eventuell mal
wieder rückabwickeln zu wollen er frage
ich mich haben sie keine besseren
eigenen Ideen die sie nach vorne stellen
können das ist doch nicht Debatte würde
im Gegensatz dazu wollen wir es mutigen
Unternehmerinnen in diesem Land und
ihren Beschäftigten nachmachen Probleme
konkret angehen mutig entscheiden ins
Risiko gehen Handeln beim Ausbau von LG
beim erneuerbare beide Aufbau neuer
Industrien das kommt nicht umsonst und
deswegen bin ich Wirtschaftsminister
habe ich dankbar dass er genauso handelt
dadurch rückt in Deutschland
nachhaltiges Wachstum nachhaltiger
Wohlstand in sichtbare Reichweite
die Energie in Deutschland um den Blick
nach vorne zu wagen das ist doch die
zentrale Aufgabe die wir jetzt haben zu
skizzieren wo wollen wir hin was können
wir leisten wenn wir gemeinsam Kräfte
bündeln die Energie in Deutschland die
wird in naher Zukunft sauber bezahlbar
und sicher sein dank der Investitionen
in ein leistungsfähiges wasserstoffnetz
das jetzt in der Planung ist dass ich im
Haushalt auch konkret in Zahlen
wiederfindet dank dem massiven Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren und dank der Planungen
die jetzt anlaufen für
wasserstofffähige Gaskraftwerke das ist
der Zukunft des Energiemix in
Deutschland und der wird federführend
der wird Planungssicherheit bringen für
ganz viele Unternehmen
wir haben außerdem die Situation dass
wir sehen dass die Geopolitik viel
stärker Determinante der
Wirtschaftspolitik ist und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass wir uns in der
Rohstoffversorgung aufstellen auch dafür
haben wir im Haushalt mit dem neuen
rohstoffvorsorge getroffen dass wir nie
wieder so abhängig werden wie wir es
waren beim russischen Gas weil wir
gesehen haben wie hart ist die Menschen
und die Gesellschaft trifft wenn wir so
abhängig sind die Resilienz die
wirtschaftssicherheit die ist in diesem
Haushalt abgebildet und das ist eine
gute Entwicklung herzlichen Dank dafür
wir greifen der Grundstoffindustrie
unter die Arme die sich klimafreundlich
aufstellen will und ich sage an dieser
Stelle nicht ganz deutlich Stahl
Aluminium Zement Chemie die gehören zu
Deutschland wie es Brandenburger Tor
nach Berlin und wir stellen sicher dass
dieser Industriestandort auch diese
Grundstoffindustrie in Zukunft halten
wird und gleichzeitig ist es aber
trotzdem total wichtig neue Industrien
aufzubauen neue Ansiedlungspolitik zu
betreiben wie wir es tun bei Chips und
Halbleitern Recycling das Lied Lithium
Magnesium das ist das was gerade in
Schwarzheide an vielen anderen
Standorten in Deutschland passiert
Deutschland ist innovationsfähig und
genau darauf wollen wir die Kraft
konzentrieren
Ökonom schülerrecht hat es vor einigen
Tagen auf den Punkt gebracht das ist
schwierig geblieben in der letzten zehn
fünfzehn Jahren 400
Milliarden zinsverbilligungen sind nicht
genutzt worden um Innovationen
anzustoßen und die Infrastruktur zu
modernisieren 243 Millionen alleine das
mautes
csu-ministers einfach verpufft einfach
weg das ist das Gegenteil von
kompetenter Wirtschaftspolitik
ich wieder spreche dem Ökonomen an einem
Punkt Deutschland ist kein Volk der
Angsthasen es gibt in den es im Land so
viele kluge Unternehmerinnen die Links
dabei sind Zukunft zu gestalten für Sie
machen wir Politik an ihrer Seite stehen
wir gerade in schwierigen Zeiten
herzlichen Dank
und für die Unionsfraktion hat das Wort
Andreas Jung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Kollegin Dr dezat gerade
den amerikanischen Präsidenten zitiert
es gilte Klimaschutz und Jobs
zusammenzubringen das ist genau unser
Weg der steht hier oben als Überschrift
dieser Debatte Klimaschutz und
Wirtschaft ich sag dazu Klimaschutz
Wirtschaft und Soziales Nachhaltigkeit
in der ganzen Breite darum geht es
voranzubringen und deshalb im übrigen
reden wir nicht schlecht wie ihre
Vorwurf erhoben worden aber wir machen
uns Zorn machen uns Sorgen um die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung die nach
hinten geht wenn sie anders so auf die
Beine kommt nach vorne geht wir machen
uns Sorgen um die Klima Lücke die diese
Regierung zu verantworten hat mir keine
Sofortprogramm vorgelegt wird und wir
machen uns Sorgen darum wie wir all das
sozial abfeder und dafür haben wir
Konzepte vorgelegt wir haben Forderungen
erhoben und ich will jetzt an einem
Beispiel vertiefen die super
Abschreibung für Klima Innovation für
Investition und Klimaschutz in CO2
Reduzierung das muss doch die Antwort
sein auf den Ire dort wird mit
Milliarden mit Milliarden sie haben
zitiert wird dort angereist es gibt
Millionen der Wirtschaft geht das
Entwicklung gibt das investierte das was
gemacht wird das was in die Tat
umgesetzt und mit Milliarden und was ist
ihre Antwort in dem sogenannten
wachstumschancengesetz steht die super
Abschreibung ja endlich drin sie haben
sie in ihren Koalitionsvertrag
reingeschrieben und dann haben wir ganz
viel kritisch gesehen aber wir haben
gesagt das ist richtig das ist ein Weg
den wir begonnen haben in den letzten
Legislaturperiode mit super Abschreibung
für digitale Wirtschaftsgüter das ist
richtig und jetzt haben wir habe erstmal
und Herr Lindner erwerben und der
Kanzler die Klima Lücke auf der Bund auf
der kabinettsbank ist ja wieder deutlich
sichtbar sie haben zwei Jahre lang
nichts gemacht sie haben es auf die
lange Bank geschoben zwei Jahre lang
nichts gemacht und jetzt ist in Ihrem
Paket als Überschrift groß drauf aber
als Bonsai Lösung drin mit 390 Millionen
Euro und das soll Antwort auf der
Amerikaner sein die lachen sich kaputt
und das Formen wir das ist wirklich
Innovationen gibt es das Innovation mit
voller Kraft vorangebracht werden bei
erneuerbaren Energien in der ganzen
Breite wo ist ihre Strategie für die
Bioenergie die wird gedeckelt
diskriminiert benachteiligt wo es geht
in jedem Gesetz wo ist die Initiative
für Energieeffizienz sich mit Deckel
langsam mit Anreizen wo ist die volle
Kraft voraus beim Wasserstoff wo ist die
Initiative für
CO2-Abscheidung für natürliche senken
für technische senken und CCS da
erwarten wir nicht Lippenbekenntnisse da
erwarten wenn ich Halbherzigkeit da
erwarten wir nicht Regulierung die
Antwort auf den ARD kann kein
Subventionswettlauf sein es muss ein
Innovationswettbewerb sein und bei dem
müssen wir unterstützen stehen muss doch
unser Anspruch sein mit unseren
Technologien mit der Stärke die wir in
diesem Land hat mit Industrie mit
Forschung mit Entwicklung mit unseren
Ingenieuren mit unserem starken
Mittelstand mit dem Handwerk da die
Lösung zu präsentieren für uns um bei
uns statt des Kl sonnenschutzgesetz
aufzuweichen ist zu erreichen aber nicht
mit Regulierung mit Innovation mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien dazu
setzen wir weiterhin auf das Prinzip der
co2-bepreisung auf den emissionszielen
und den muss man glaubwürdig
ausgestalten nicht quasi auf dem Buzzer
für jedes Jahr wie sie es machen die
Preise aushandeln und die soziale Flanke
die soziale Frage die soziale Akzeptanz
dadurch beschädigen dass sie zwar ein
Klimagerät Versprechen ist aber nicht
umsetzen und die Mittel dafür längst für
alles andere mögliche verplant haben so
beschädigt man diese Instrument wir
treten dafür ein es glaubwürdig
auszugestalten weil das ist die
Botschaft
CO2-Ausstoß kostet Geld ist lohnt sich
zu investieren in klimatechnologien ist
lohnt sich zu investieren in Klimaschutz
und so bringt das zusammen das ist
nachhaltige Politik für die stehen mir
hat sie denken
und für die SPD-Fraktion spricht nun dr
Matthias Mersch
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist die Haushaltsdebatte
und deswegen kann es auch mal
grundsätzlicher werden und Herr Kollege
Wiehle ich will das ausdrücklich zu
ihnen jetzt am Anfang sagen wenn Sie
sich hier hinstellen und wir sind ein
Verfassungsorgan und sagen der
menschengemachte Klimawandel ist nicht
bestätigt und sie stellen sich mit ihren
Ausführungen gegen das Pariser
Klimaschutzabkommen das 195 Staaten
dieser Welt unterschrieben haben dann
handeln sie gegen das deutsche
Grundgesetz dann handeln sie gegen die
deutsche Verfassung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
lesen Sie sich sehr genau die
verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung durch
die wir dazu bekommen haben es ist nicht
zu tolerieren solche Aussagen hier
widerspruchslos hinzunehmen
und Liebe Kollege Spahn und liebe
Kollegin Klöckner sie haben die
Regierungsfähigkeit angezweifelt und
Frau Kollegin Klöckner sie haben eine
Bestandsanalyse angefordert ich will
Ihnen mal sagen an zwei Beispielen weil
man da ja deutlich machen kann wofür
stehen sie und wofür steht eigentlich
die Ampel auf zwei Dinge ist es massiv
angekommen im letzten Jahr das erste war
die Versorgungssicherheit in diesem Land
zu gewährleisten ihr Vorschlag war das
gassenbargo gegenüber Russland wir haben
geliefert wir haben die
Versorgungssicherheit sichergestellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das zweite war dass wir die
Energiepreise in den Griff bekommen
wollten wer hat gegen die 200 Milliarden
Wirtschaft stabilisierungsform gestimmt
wer hat diese Preisstabilität
gewährleistet das war die Ampel nicht
sie liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und weil das jetzt immer wieder kommt
und wer eine gemeinsame Geschichte haben
wir auch noch mal sagen wenn sie jetzt
meinen
Atomkraft sei die Lösung es gibt an
keiner Stelle augenblicklich ein belegt
dass die Abschaltung der Atomkraftwerke
zu Preissteigerungen geführt hat in
diesem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist eine mehr
wir haben gestern wir haben gestern wir
im Gegenteil wir haben gestern hier
gehört dass über die Hälfte des
Bundesumweltministeriums dafür draufgeht
für die endlagerkosten reden sie doch
nicht von billiger Energie wenn es um
Atomkraft geht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und irgendwann hat man ja den Eindruck
dass wir hier Frau Klöckner redete vom
Geisterfahrer gibt ja den schönen sitzt
da hört einer kommt einer entgegen und
er sagt einer tausende
Frau Frau Klöckner sie so gerieren hier
das überall neue Atomkraftwerke gebaut
werden darf ich Ihnen mal sagen wie viel
Giger wird letztes Jahr dazu gebaut
worden weltweit es sind 4 Gigawatt ganze
vier Gigabyte wie viel erneuerbare sind
dazu gekommen
295 GB das ist die Zukunft liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und deswegen sind wir hier wieder an
einem sehr sehr entscheidenden Punkt
weil wir es doch bei der
Laufzeitverlängerung unter der Merkel
Regierung gesehen haben was passierte
die Industrie die
Photovoltaikindustrie die wendekraft sie
ist aus diesem Land rausgegangen sie
haben den Wirtschaftsstandort gefährdet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und darum geht es wenn AFD und Teile der
CDU wieder generieren hier wäre
Atomkraft die Lösung sie machen
Zukunftstechnologien kaputt sie setzen
die Exportnation Deutschlands aus Spiel
nicht mit uns liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und für die afd-fraktion spricht jetzt
Carsten Hilse
[Applaus]
wer das Präsidium meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute wir alle wissen was ein
Phantomschmerz ist für alle die es nicht
mehr in der Schule gelernt haben Liebe
grüne ein Phantomschmerz ist ein
Schmerzgefühl das Auftritt zum Beispiel
das betroffene Bein nicht mehr da ist es
tut also weh obwohl nicht da ist was weh
tun könnte und ähnlich könnte man den
neuen Haushalt bezeichnen ein
phantomhaushalt denn er sagt geldausgang
zu Geldauszahlung zu mit Geld das zu
einem großen Teil nicht da ist
jedenfalls nicht durch Erspartes gedeckt
nicht und erst recht nicht durchlaufende
Einnahmen doch anders als beim
Phantomschmerz wird nicht nur nicht
vorhandenes Geld durch Schulden ersetzt
sondern das Geld der Steuerzahler auch
noch für Dinge ausgegeben die ebenfalls
nicht da sind in der Juristerei nennt
man das wohl betrug beispielsweise gibt
es nur zwei Geschlechter aber diese
Regierung behauptet den Orbit wenn man
nie es gebe mehr und schafft mit dem
wiederum in Orwell schon mal nie
selbst
bestimmungsgesetz genannt nur
erziehungsbonstrument tausende von
kostspieligen neuen Stellen mit denen
die Umsetzung natürlich auch durch
Denunziationen unterhalb der
strafbarkeitsschwelle wie es heißt
überwachtiert die gängelt und umgesetzt
werden muss rein haushaltstechnisch ist
dieser menschenfeindliche Ausfluss aber
nur ein kleiner Fisch
zu den ganz großen Fischen gehört es
Phantom Klimaschutz dafür wird das Geld
mit vollen Händen hinausgeworfen zu
lassen der jetzigen Generation die
unserer Kinder Enkel und sogar Urenkel
sie versündigen sich also für ein
Hirngespinst an den nächsten
Generationen und wofür selbst wenn die
von Ihnen zur unantastbaren Religion
erhobene Hypothese dass die
menschengemachten CO2-Emissionen des
Klima maßgeblich beeinflussen stimmen
würde könnte Deutschland wenn es von
heute auf morgen keinerlei CO2 durch
Industrie heizen Verkehr Landwirtschaft
und so weiter also wirklich keinerlei
CO2 ausstoßen würde die hypothetische
Erderwärmung um
0,0056 Grad verringern ein befreundeter
Wissenschaftler hat um den Irrsinn zu
verdeutlichen errechnet wie viele
fossile CO2 aus Deutschland denn in der
Atmosphäre vorhanden ist es ist Sarah
und schreibe ein fossiles co2-molekül
aus Deutschland auf zwei Komma zwei zwei
Millionen Luftmoleküle wenn nun die
Grünen Kommunisten in allen Altparteien
manche sind doch nur etwas weniger
gebildet uns erzählen wenn wir unsere
gesamte Wirtschaft zerstören dem
deutschen Volk als die Lebensgrundlage
entziehen um dieses eine fossile Molekül
auf 2,2 Millionen Luftmoleküle zu
vermeiden wir die Welt retten ist das
wie man an den Zahlen sehen kann eine
dreiste doch eine Zwischenfrage es geht
um die gezielte Verarmung des deutschen
Volkes durch gnadenlose ausblende und
Enteignung um die erzielte erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage selbstverständlich
sie haben ja eben hier über die
Zukunftsaussichten der deutschen
Wirtschaft gesprochen
Beschlusslage ihre Partei ist es ja aus
der Europäischen Union austreten zu
wollen die Europäische Union gänzlich
umzubauen und damit das Fundament zu
entziehen auf dem unsere Exportnation
Deutschland basiert wir sind darauf
angewiesen auf europäische
Zusammenarbeit auf Export wir sind
darauf angewiesen und es eine
Erfolgsgeschichte die Europäische Union
dieser Erfolgsgeschichte wollen sie
wegen ihren nationalen waren kaputt
machen sie wollen sich ernsthaft
hinstellen und wollen andere als eine
Gefahr für den Wirtschaftsstandort
darstellt obwohl die größte Gefahr für
den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland von
der Programmatik ihrer Partei ausgeht
vielen Dank für die Frage wenn sie
richtig gelesen hätten dann würden sie
lesen können also wenn sie können lesen
das weiß ich Entschuldigung dann würden
sie lesen dass wir nicht einfach nur die
EU auflösen wollen sondern wir wollen
einen auf wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
basierende neue Gemeinschaft bilden so
wie es zum Beispiel vorher die EWG war
oder die Europäische Gemeinschaft das
was jetzt in Brüssel ist das ist ein das
ist ein Bürokratiemonster die sich in
jede in jeden einzelnen Bereich unseres
Lebens hineindrängt 90 Prozent aller
Gesetze die hier beschlossen werden
gehen auf EU-Initiativen zurück wir
wollen unsere Souveränität wir wollen
Subsidiarität und das ist das was die EU
aushebelt und Deutschland braucht nicht
dieses Bürokratiemonster um wieder auf
die Beine zu kommen es braucht eine AFD
geführte Bundesregierung die
Vernunft geleitet der Industriepolitik
macht
es geht um durch böswürdigkeit
angetriebene zur Störung unserer
Wirtschaft und unsere Lebensgrundlagen
eine AFD geführte Bundesregierung wird
jede CO2 beweisen und geht wieder
Anstrengung zur Vermeidung von CO2
aufgrund ihrer offensichtlichen
Unwirksamkeit beenden und im Übrigen bin
ich der Meinung der grün wird den Krieg
ich bedanke mich
und für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun das
Wort Olaf in der Beek
ja frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir haben es von vielen Rednern im
Vorfeld gerade gehört wir haben in der
Tat viel vor und setzen auf solide und
nachhaltige Finanzen das ist kein
Widerspruch sondern Ansporn für uns
denn eins ist für uns ganz entscheidend
Effizienz in Zeiten ein angespannten
Haushaltslage ist es wichtiger denn je
dass wir Aussagen auf den Prüfstand
stellen und ganz genau schauen wo das
Geld mit bester Wirkung eingesetzt wird
die Haushaltsdisziplin inklusive
Schuldenbremse ist für uns nicht
verhandelbar wir müssen mit dem was wir
uns zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen und
was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
erarbeitet haben zurechtkommen denn der
Staat hat kein Einnahme sondern ein
Ausgabenproblem Liebe Kolleg Kollegen
wir brauchen auch spürbare Entlastung
für Wirtschaft und insbesondere den
Mittelstand wie Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner am Dienstag bereits
treffen sagte die Balance aus Staat und
privat muss wieder hergestellt werden
wir entlasten
wir entlasten die Menschen nicht nur um
Ihnen mehr finanziellen Spielraum für
ein selbstbestimmtes Leben zu geben
sondern beschleunigen dadurch natürlich
auch den Klimaschutz Unternehmen
brauchen dringender denn je den nötigen
Freiraum um Investitionen in
Nachhaltigkeit und klimafreundliche
Technologien zu tätigen es ist weder
originäre Aufgabe noch leistbar für den
Staat hier für Investitionen zu sorgen
es ist unsere Aufgabe die richtigen
Rahmenbedingungen zu setzen und das das
tun wir am besten
und wie der Kollege jung zu Recht gesagt
hat mit dem Emissionshandel denn der
Nachweis ist längs erbracht dass er
zielsicher und effizient Klimaschutz
liefert zentrale Aufgabe muss daher sein
wie es Instrument weiter zu entwickeln
und damit ganz konkret klimafreundliche
Investitionen anzureizen mit Eingriffen
mit Eingriffen in den Marktwirtschaft
sollten wir hingegen so vorsichtig wie
möglich umgehen und lassen Sie mich auch
ein paar Worte was gerade angesprochen
worden ist zum Klima Geld sagen seine
Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit und
Verlässlichkeit dass wir hier endlich
Vorankommen
2024 das wissen wir ist der Mechanismus
fertig und überhaupt 85 Millionen
Direktüberweisung vornehmen zu können
ein beträchtlicher Teil der Mittel im
Klima und transformationsform muss dann
aber ab 2025 für das Klimagerät
eingesetzt werden und ja dafür müssen
wir so wie es einigen tun wird auch
mittelfristig unsere Subventionspolitik
überdenken liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Haushalt ist voller
Herausforderung aber ich bin ganz
zuversichtlich dass wir am Ende des
Jahres ein Ergebnis haben mit dem wir
nicht nur den Standort Deutschland
besser machen können sondern auch
effizienten Klimaschutz betreiben ich
freue mich auf die weiteren
Verhandlungen
üssen dankeschön
[Applaus]
und für die SPD-Fraktion spricht nun dr
Nina Scheer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn wir über
den Haushalt sprechen und wenn wir uns
per gegenwärtigen was auch schon gestern
beim Auftakt zu dieser haushaltswoche
wie auch heute im Mittelpunkt auch das
Wettstreits zwischen den Fraktionen
steht da möchte ich zusammenfassen dass
die Koalition ganz klar für die Stärkung
des innovationsstandortes Deutschland
steht und die Opposition ganz klar für
das schlecht reden dieses Standortes
steht das ist ein
das ist als Signal in die Welt und jedes
Land auf dieser Erde ist gerade in
Zeiten des Klimawandels immer als ein
Element eines Ganzen zu sehen also
dieses Zeichen was wir hier gerade
aussenden ist mit Blick auf das was die
Opposition sich hier leistet höchst
bedauerlich und schädlich und deswegen
bitte ich Sie dringend zu einer
Kehrtwende dieser rückwärtsgewandten
Politik die sich natürlich leider auch
an Einzelvorschlägen festmachen lässt
die allesamt untauglich sind und den
Innovationsstandort Deutschland zu
stärken
und ich kann hier nahtlos auch an meinen
Vorräten aus der Fraktion automatias
Mirsch anknüpfen wenn sich hier allen
Ernstes im Jahr 2023 die Atome Energie
wiederbeleben möchten dann ignorieren
sie das Weltgeschehen und sie ignorieren
auch die Rolle Deutschlands die wir in
den
industrialisierungszeiten immer
eingenommen haben nämlich
Innovationsmotor zu sein auch neue
Technologien zu entwickeln und es muss
sie doch ihnen doch einen Warnsignal
sein das unter Schwarz-Geld damals
eingeleitet unter das ist damals
passiert ist dass uns der
solarindustriestandort verloren gegangen
war das muss ihn doch ein Warnsignal
sein dass wir fast täglich
Schwierigkeiten bekommen oder immer noch
nachfolgewirkungen aus diesen Jahren
verspüren weil wir gar nicht so schnell
hinterher kommen diese ganzen Hemmnisse
abzubauen die dort aufgebaut wurden das
muss ihm doch ein Warnsignal sein dass
wir immer noch diese Folgewirkungen
spüren also muss doch die Konsequenz aus
diesen Folgewirkungen sein dass wir
volle Kraft auf diese erneuerbaren
Energien auf diesen
Transformationsprozess lenken und nicht
die Herr Jung die sie sagen jetzt auf
bepreisungsmodalitäten setzen die ja
immer erst sehr pauschal und spät wirken
und erstmal den die Kraft rausnehmen aus
dieser Innovationskraft die wir jetzt
brauchen es ist ein
kraftsenkungspotenzial was sie
vorschlagen und kein Kraft
stärkungspotenzial was wir jetzt
bei der Atomenergie muss zudem auch mal
einmal noch mal erwähnt werden das ist
ergänzend zu den Argumenten noch mal
zugefügt es gibt weltweit kein einziges
Land was ohne eine staatliche
Versicherungs Höchstgrenze auskommt es
ist nebelhudelei die hier
Betrieb hat diese Energiegewinnung geht
auch das ist ein Trugschluss der ständig
immer wieder übergangen wird oder das
ist eine eine Fehlannahme die ständig
wieder im Raum gestellt wird dass
Atomenergie ökonomisch nein nein das
Gegenteil ist richtig die Erneuerbaren
in den liegt die Kraft und jetzt kommt
diese haben wir eben diese
Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten auch
vorgesehen und setzt sich hier auf diese
Förderung vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und Hans Jörg dortz ist der nächste
Redner für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werde
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
vor wenigen Monaten noch hat der
Bundeskanzler unserem Land ein grünes
Wirtschaftswunder versprochen
was wir mittlerweile erleben ist ein
blaues Wirtschaftswunder allein in der
Industrie haben wir den größten
Auftragsrückgang seit Corona und auch
die Produktion geht zurück und es ist
kein schlechter reden das ist schlicht
und einfach die Realität
die die Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
korrigieren ihre
Prognosen nach unten mittlerweile auf
Schrumpfung
von Tag zu Tag sind es mehr die ihre
Zahlen korrigieren und die Ampel hat
sich dieser Realität lange nicht
gestellt und verschleppt den
wirtschaftspolitisch so wichtigen Wandel
die zeitenwände auch in der
Wirtschaftspolitik es sind nicht nur die
hohe Inflation Energiepreise auf weitere
kartenniveau eine überbordnende
Bürokratie und mangelnde Fachkräfte nein
es ist für die Unternehmen und die
Unternehmen mehr äußern das tagtäglich
auch mittlerweile
ein echtes standardrisiko diese
Bundesregierung
warum
warum das zeigt auch dieser Haushalt
sehr deutlich auf denn es fehlt an drei
Dingen an Transparenz an Mut und dann
Ideen an Transparenz mangelt es diesem
Haushaltsentwurf weil er die waren
Kosten und Ausgaben verschleiert ganze
Haushaltspositionen
Milliardenbeträge wie etwa zur Förderung
der Mikroelektronik sind aus dem
Kernhaushalt
abgewandert in den Klima und
transformationsfonds noch nie waren so
viele Ausgaben
wie es Haushalte formulieren Budget
flüchtig Deutschland erlebt damit die
größte finanzpolitische Fluchtbewegung
liebe Kolleginnen Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen
doch diesem Haushalt mangelt es nicht
nur an Transparenz sondern vor allem an
Mut zum Gestalten aus den Zahlen zum
Haushalt ergibt sich keine klare
Zielrichtung keine
Prioritätensetzung der Ausgaben einzelne
grüne Lieblinge werden noch stärker als
bisher gefördert gespart wird hingegen
im Bereich Innovation Technologie und
neue Mobilität ausgerechnet in Bereichen
die entscheidend für die
Zukunftsfähigkeit dieses unseres Landes
sind
und im übrigen
das ist auch Realität sagen das auch
Mitglieder ihres Sachverständigenrates
wir brauchen zwingend mehr Priorität für
Investitionen was zudem fehlt
ist eine Idee eine Idee womit
Deutschland künftig den Wohlstand
erwirtschaften soll eine Idee für
Wirtschaftswachstum und wie dramatisch
ist um ihren Ideenreichtum bestellt ist
zeigt exemplarisch ein Haushaltstitel
der mit einem zwar einstelligen
Millionenbetrag mit sechs Millionen doch
etwas klein erscheint aber ungeheuer
viel aussagt erhalten soll dieses Geld
der Rat für Nachhaltige Entwicklung und
wofür um Ideen zu entwickeln wie die
Meldepflichten des
nachhaltigkeitskodex für Mittelständler
abgebaut und vereinfacht werden können
meine Damen und Herren das ist nicht nur
in Zahlen gegossenes Eingeständnis dass
ihre Politik
Bürokratiemonster hervorbringt sie
gestehen damit auch ein dass sie selbst
keine Ideen entwickeln können wie sie es
besser machen können
Bürokratien zur Energie zur Ideen zur
bürokratieentlastung liegen zahlreiche
vor allein die Verbände und Unternehmen
haben über 400 Vorschläge unterbreitet
in ihr Konzept in ihre Eckpunkte sind
gerade mal 28
eingeflossen kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss soll so der neue Deutschland
packt aussehen das zeigt wie weit in
dieser Bundesregierung Reden und Handeln
auseinanderklaffen vielen Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Bernd Westphal
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die
Haushaltsdebatte ist ein wichtiger
Bereich in dieser Woche weil wir über
eine entscheidende Zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres Landes reden viel ist Dir
beschrieben worden und ich will mal das
Fenster aufmachen und ein bisschen
Wirklichkeit reinlassen wie es an diesem
Standort aussieht wir stehen weltweit an
vierter Stelle des
Bruttoinlandsprodukt und das mit 46
Millionen Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern ich finde das ist eine
hervorragende Leistung
wir stehen
wir stehen bei den weltweiten Exporten
an dritter Stelle hinter China und den
USA ich finde das ist eine großartige
Leistung von den Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern die für wettbewerbsfähige
Produkte auf globalen Märkten sorgen das
ist mal etwas auf das man hinweisen muss
und vielleicht noch ein drittes hier
wurde der Auftragsrückgang in der
Industrie beschrieben also sie sollten
solche Meldungen auch mal ganz lesen da
steht nämlich drin dass im Vormonat
durch Großaufträge wie zum Beispiel 900
Flugzeuge die Zahlen nach oben
geschnellt sind und dann natürlich im
Folge Monat sich wieder normalisieren
hieraus zu machen dass unsere Industrie
den Bach runtergeht das ist absolut
nicht richtig
diese Haushalt ist gekennzeichnet von
Investition über 100 Milliarden
staatlichen Investitionen die private
Investition unterstützen wir werden
entlasten dort wo sie den Unternehmen
darum geht Zukunftsfähigkeit
Investitionen nach vorne zu bringen in
der erneuerbare Energien in den Hochlauf
von Wasserstoff Infrastruktur von
elektrolyseapparaten das ist Innovation
und nicht gerne Energie die konservativ
zurückgewandt in eine vorherige Welt
sind wir gestalten Zukunft und die sieht
erneuerbar aus
dieser Haushalt ist gekennzeichnet da
das macht auch der Einzelplan 09 klar
dass wir neben Investitionen und neben
Entlastung auch den Zusammenhalt in
unserer Gesellschaft organisieren ich
will das ganz klar sagen als
Sozialdemokratin und Sozialdemokraten
ist es für uns wichtig dass wir nicht
auf den Schwächsten in dieser
Gesellschaft auf dem Rücken rumtrampeln
sondern wir helfen diesen Menschen dass
sie wieder ein eigenes selbstbestimmtes
Leben führen können und deshalb ist es
richtig den Mindestlohn zu erhöhen
deshalb ist es richtig Renten aus West
anzugleichen deshalb ist das richtig das
Bürgergeld auf den Weg zu bringen das
ist das was auch ökonomische Stärke in
diesem Land ausmacht dass wir die
soziale Stärke mitdenken in dieser
Politik
ein letztes weil das ja in der cdu/csu
Fraktion nicht so richtig verstanden
worden ist das also ich muss mir
manchmal wundern wenn der
wirtschaftspolitischen Kompetenz ist das
nicht weit her es war schon mal besser
aber wenn der Bundeskanzler hier steht
und einen Deutschland packt anbietet
dann finde ich sollte man das ernst
nehmen und sollte das seriös auch in
Anspruch nehmen weil er damit beschreibt
dass wir eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe haben
damit solche Leute wie hier auf der
rechten Seite im Parlament keinen
Einfluss in dieser Gesellschaft reden
und für die unionfraktion hat das Wort
Jannik Burri
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es geht nicht
darum wenn man die aktuelle
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung anspricht
des Land schlecht zu reden oder schwarz
zu malen es geht darum dass wir uns hier
politisch Sorge machen müssen wenn wir
im internationalen Vergleich sehen dass
die Weltwirtschaft um drei Prozent
wächst dass die USA um 1,8% wachsen die
Eurozone 0,9% Frankreich 0,8 % und
Zahlen Prognose von dieser Woche des
Instituts zur Weltwirtschaft die
deutsche Volkswirtschaft um 0,5%
schrumpft das muss doch Sorgen machen
das muss doch eine Regierungskoalition
auch alarmieren und wenn man sich dann
anguckt was sind denn die Ursachen
hinter dieser Entwicklung dann sind das
natürlich zum einen die Effekte die
Folgen der inflationskrise und deswegen
muss natürlich die Priorität in diesem
Haushalt darauf liegen Inflation zu
bremsen Inflation nicht weiter Einzel
nicht weiter einzuhalten deswegen
fordern wir ja gerade senken Sie die
Strom senken Sie die Netzentgelte um die
Preise zu reduzieren dann gehört zur
Wahrheit aber auch dazu
dass wir es nicht nur mit einer
inflationskrise sondern auch mit einer
investitionskrise im Land zu tun haben
und zwar nicht bei den öffentlichen
sondern bei den privaten Investitionen
das Firmen nicht mehr
im ich schieben das erst
recht kein Ausland im Inland investiert
wird und das führt auch das Zahlen von
IfW in Kiel dazu dass aufgrund des
Rückgangs der privaten Investitionen
dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal der
Kapitalstock der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft schrumpft und diese
Investitionsentscheidung haben etwas zu
tun mit Standortfaktoren mit
Standortbedingungen und das natürlich
Standortfaktoren nach 21 Jahren SPD
Regierungsbeteiligung leiden kann
niemanden überraschen aber am Ende vom
Tag ist ein Standortfaktor auch die
Frage ob wir es mit verlässlicher
Politik ob wir es mit erträglichen und
verlässlichen Regeln zu tun haben und
anders gewendet es ist Gift für jede
Investitionsentscheidung wenn
Unsicherheit herrscht und er
Bundeswirtschaftsminister nachdem sie
nun fast zwei Jahre im Amt sind muss man
feststellen ihre Wirtschaftspolitik hat
der Wirtschaftspolitik in Deutschland
die Verlässlichkeit genommen hat im
Ausmaß die Erträglichkeit genommen Herr
Bundesminister man muss es leider so
deutlich sagen mit ihrer Politik sind
sie die personifizierte
investitionsunsicherheit der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen banatschak sehr gerne
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Burri dass sie
die Zwischenfrage zulassen wir uns ein
die Sorge und ich sage das auch sehr
deutlich in der Tonlage vorgetragen wie
sie das gemacht und auch wieder durch
das gemacht hat da Chor ja niemand sagt
hier Robert havix sagt das nicht niemand
von uns sagt alles tutti was uns nicht
eint ist die Analyse der Ursachen dieser
Situation ich weiß dass sie sich ungern
damit beschäftigen dass die Abhängigkeit
von Russland in der Energiepolitik die
Deutschland sehr sehr viel stärker hatte
als beispielsweise Frankreich
55%, das ist 24% Erdgas er hat dass sie
sich damit nicht beschäftigen wollen
weil das in ihre Regierungszeit fällt
sie beschäftigt sich aber auch mit einer
zweiten Frage nicht Jahr für Jahr haben
sie sich hier abgefeiert im Plenum
Deutschland ist Exportweltmeister wir
sind so toll dieser großen
Exportüberschüsse die teilweise die
Europäische Union ziemlich die
stabilisiert haben das ist doch alles
super und wenn das so ist dann können
sie doch nicht völlig verdutzt aus der
Wäsche gucken das ganze doch ab dann
können sie doch nicht völlig verdutzt
außer Wäsche gucken dass in der
Situation in der der Welthandel
insgesamt stoppt und jetzt zwar nicht
China von denen wir uns so abhängig
gemacht haben unsere Unternehmen so
abhängig gemacht haben wenn dieser Motor
stottert dass das dann auch in einer
exportorientierten Wirtschaft die
Deutschland ankommt wollen Sie
vielleicht sagen dass es auch etwas
damit zu tun haben könnte und wollen Sie
vielleicht ein bisschen anerkennen das
ist auch die Politik der letzten Jahre
ist und nicht der letzten zwei sein
etwas davor die uns in die Situation
gebracht haben jetzt tatsächlich
herausfordernd ist
Herr Kollege Herr Kollege bannaschak sie
machen in ihrer Analyse wieder einen
ganz grundsätzlichen Fehler und das ist
dass sie die kurzfristigen
konjunkturellen Effekte auf der einen
Seite die gerade und ich habe es ja
angesprochen inflationstreibend wirken
durcheinander werfen mit den
strukturellen Effekten mit den
strukturellen standardproblemen die dazu
führen dass Investitionen zurückgehalten
werden und wenn man sich in der
Situation wenn man anschaut wie denn
ihre Politik als Reaktion auf diese
Probleme die richtig zugenommen haben
wie ihre Politik als Reaktion auf diese
Probleme ausgesehen hat dann ist es beim
Thema Energie der das Abscheiden der
drei Atomkraftwerke die sie hätten
verlängern können das Angebot verknappt
dann ist es beim Thema fahren
Arbeitskräftemangel Anreize gesetzt
haben dann ist es beim Thema Bürokratie
Verlässlichkeit von Regeln des
heizungsgesetz weil sie diese Woche hier
durch den Bundestag Peitschen sie
beheben den standortprobleme nicht sie
vergrößern die standortprobleme unserer
Volkswirtschaft vergrößern damit die
investitionskrise unserer
Volkswirtschaft
und diese und diese Freunde
Verlässlichkeit die zeigt sich eben auch
im Haushaltsentwurf den sie uns
vorgelegt haben für die Haushaltsdebatte
dass sie gerade nicht auf
Investitionssicherheit setzen dass sie
gerade nicht darauf setzen insbesondere
dem Mittelstand den Handwerkern den
kleinen mittleren Betrieben die das
Rückgrat unserer Volkswirtschaft sind
Sicherheit zu geben im übrigen auch dem
Tourismus die können im Zweifel nämlich
nicht woanders investieren können im
Zweifel nicht gehen sondern die haben
nur die Wahl zuzumachen wenn sie in
dieser Unsicherheit gefangen sind die
sie mit ihrer Politik schaffen und
die Verlässlichkeit nehmen Sie nicht nur
nehmen Sie nicht nur in ihrer
Wirtschaftspolitik sie nehmen die
Verlässlichkeit auch in der Klimapolitik
Andreas Jung hat es eben schon
angesprochen in dem der grundsätzlichen
Umwandlung des Klima und
transformationsfonds ursprünglich einmal
geschaffen um die Einnahmen aus der CO2
Bepreisung Zweck zu binden sie dann in
Klimaschutz investieren zu können Sie
dann am Ende auch zurückgeben zu können
an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger unterfrage
ich mich wo ist denn das Klima Geld in
ihrem Haushaltsentwurf geblieben jetzt
haben wir eben gehört es kommt 2025 ich
bin gespannt ich bin gespannt ob es
wirklich so sein wird weil die Mittel im
Klima und Transformation vor ja bereits
vollständig vollständig anderweitig
wieder verplant sind auch da nimmt ihre
Politik Sicherheit schafft zusätzliche
Unsicherheit
und deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zeichnet der Haushaltsentwurf
sowohl im Einzelplan 09 als auch beim
Klima und Transformation vor dass er von
Ideologie atmet dass er die Unsicherheit
verstärkt dass er damit die
investitionskrise in diesem Land
zementieren werden wir werden Ihnen in
den nächsten Wochen konkrete Vorschläge
in den Haushaltsberatungen machen wie
wir Investitionssicherheit stärken
können ich appelliere schon heute ein
Ziel Zwischenziel das nicht einfach
beiseite nehmen Sie die Sorgen ernst
nehmen Sie dann die Vorschläge die wir
Ihnen machen auch entsprechend ernst und
kriegen sie endlich die Kurve hinzu mehr
Investitionssicherheit in diesem Land
vielen Dank
der nächste Redner ist Robert Falle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
ich empfehle jedem die heutige Debatte
nach Möglichkeit auch in der Bevölkerung
mal nachzuvollziehen ein solchen
Realitätsverlust wir heute bei den
Grünen aufgetreten ist in diesem
Parlament habe ich selten erlebt
sie haben noch nicht mal geschnallt
wohin unsere Probleme bestehen
die Wirtschaft schrumpft die Pleitewelle
rollt die Inflation galoppiert und sie
wird vorangetrieben durch die
Schuldenpolitik dieses Staates
durch die CO2 Bepreisung
und dem Herrn Harbeck fällt nur eins ein
es war Putins Krieg der Putin hat uns
den grasan abgedreht die Wahrheit weiß
doch die ganze Bevölkerung dass die
Grünen seit vielen Jahren fordern von
Russlands Abhängigkeit wichtig zu kommen
und die durch die amerikanische
Abhängigkeit durch die Abhängigkeit von
einem beiden zu ersetzen damit die
Preise alle dreimal so teuer werden das
ist doch die grüne Politik und diese
Politik der Grünen muss
rückabgewickelt werden die Energiewende
muss rückabgewickelt werden denn zu
allem obendrein sind sie noch
hergegangen und haben die Preise in der
Energie so hochgetrieben dass unsere
Industrie zum Teil abwandern will weil
sie von den USA geködert wird mit
Subventionen
das weiß doch auch mittlerweile jeder
die ganze Wirtschaft weiß das die
Arbeitnehmer wissen das sie haben selbst
die Wirtschaft ins Chaos reingebracht
und deswegen sage ich sie sind ein guter
Kinderbuchautor vielleicht ich habe ihre
Bücher ja nicht gelesen aber sie können
die Zukunft mit einer Clownsnase kommen
und den Leuten noch dieses mal
interessieren dass sie gar nichts mit
dieser Wirtschaftskrise zu tun haben sie
haben
sie müssen überall aus dem Parlamenten
abgewählt werden und zwar so schnell wie
möglich damit wieder Kernkraft kommt und
damit wieder billige Strompreise kommen
für die Haushalte und die Industrie
[Applaus]
und nun spricht für die SPD der Kollege
Andreas Mehltretter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ist ja schon immer
wieder erstaunlich was man hier im
Bundestag manchmal so zu hören bekommt
der Klimawandel ist aber real und
deswegen haben wir bei der Energiewende
ja schon viel angepackt und auch
erreicht in den nicht einmal zwei Jahren
muss man immer wieder dazu sagen
Ampelkoalition wir haben aber auch noch
viel vor das was wir vorhaben das
schaffen wir nur mit einem guten
Haushalt der die Mittel dort vorsieht wo
sie gebraucht werden bei Investitionen
in erneuerbare Energien statt alten
Ideen wieder Atomkraft in grüne
Industrie und klimafreundliche Heizungen
und natürlich bei der sozialen
Absicherung all dieser
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen damit niemand vom
Klimaschutz überfordert wird das alles
ermöglicht dieser Haushalt für das Jahr
rund 19 Millionen Milliarden Euro sollen
im Klima und Transformation vor für
Gebäude Sanierungen und neue Heizungen
bereitstehen wenn wir morgen das Gebäude
Energiegesetz verabschieden dann können
sich die Menschen darauf verlassen dass
Sie sich dieses Gesetz auch leisten
können dafür steht dieser Haushalt meine
Damen und Herren
der Haushalt steht auch dafür dass wir
wirklich in allen Bereichen der
Energiewende Vorankommen bis 2027 werden
wir dann über 18 Milliarden Euro für den
Aufbau der wasserstoffindustrie zur
Verfügung stellen rund 14 Milliarden
Euro zur Förderung der Elektromobilität
und rund 12 Milliarden für die
Bahninfrastruktur so bringen wir
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz zusammen
genauso wie sie jetzt doch angeblich
wollen Liebe Union und das alles können
wir auch nur tun wenn wir den
klimaantransformationsvorhaben also
stellen Sie sich bitte nicht hier hin
und sagen was sie alles gerne toll
machen wollen wenn Sie gleichzeitig in
Karlsruhe genau gegen diese Mittel im
Klima und Transformation vor Klagen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Union
nichtsdestotrotz zeigt sich auch im
Bereich der Energie und Klimapolitik
dass der Haushalt kein einfacher ist um
die Ausgaben auch finanzieren zu können
schlägt die Bundesregierung vor den
CO2-Preis ansteigen zu lassen stärker
als eigentlich geplant natürlich
unterstützt dieses Preissignal die
notwendige Transformation aber und das
sind wir uns ja heute sehr einig hier
der im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart des
soziale Ausgleich mit Mechanismus fehlt
noch der muss kommen wir brauchen auch
beim Klima Geld ein deutschlandtempo
meine Damen und Herren
mit diesem Tempo haben wir es ja im
letzten Jahr auch geschafft die
Energiekrise in den Griff zu bekommen
die preisbremsen waren eine Volk noch
erfolgreicher waren wir dabei die
Gasversorgung sicherzustellen wir
konnten die Preise dadurch schneller
senken als vorhergesagt 60 Milliarden
Euro die im Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds eingeplant waren um
die Energiekrise abzufedern werden
deswegen voraussichtlich nicht zur
direkten Stabilisierung der Preise
benötigt Geld mit dem wir der Wirtschaft
aus der Energiekrise helfen können und
Geld mit dem wir auch sind ein
transformationsstrompreis finanzieren
können so wie wir das ja wollten mit dem
Wirtschaft stabilisierungsfond zur
Abfederung der Auswirkungen der
Energiekrise
großen Einsatz bringen wir die
Energiewende voran und dieser Haushalt
bringt uns dafür stellt uns dafür die
notwendigen Mittel zur Verfügung
[Applaus]
und die nächste Rednerin ist Johanna
frau Präsidentin Werte Kollegen wenn der
Internationale Währungsfonds für dieses
Jahr prognostiziert dass Deutschland die
einzige Industrienation sein wird deren
Volkswirtschaft schrumpft während selbst
das mit Sanktionen belegte Russland
wachsen wird dann weiß man dass der
Fachkräftemangel vor allem im
Wirtschaftsministerium angekommen ist
über 43% aller Industrieunternehmen in
Deutschland überlegen ihre Kapazitäten
ins Ausland zu verlegen das wird
Deutschland 120 Milliarden Euro
Wirtschaftsleistungen und 1,3 Millionen
Jobs kosten statt Doppel Wumms erleben
wir gerade die die Industrialisierung
unseres Landes der industriestrompreis
ist von 2020 bis 22 und 155% gestiegen
anstatt die Bürokratisierung zu
bekämpfen werden die Unternehmen mit
ständig neuen Vorschriften bombardiert
vom lieferkettengesetz bis zur
Dokumentation der Müllentsorgung anstatt
für massive Steuererleichterung zu
sorgen zementiert die Ampel Deutschlands
Spitzenposition als höchste
unser Land ist nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig und das zeigen auch die
15 Milliarden Euro Subventionen für
internenpo auf die die Ampel auch noch
stolz ist liebe Leute wenn unser Land
ein attraktiver Wirtschaftsstandort wäre
dann bräuchten wir diese Investitionen
Subventionen gar nicht und darauf könnte
man dann tatsächlich stolz sein
stattdessen ist Deutschland weiter der
kranke Mann Europas und jetzt will habe
das mit einer
industriestrompreisbremse auffangen ja
geht's noch wieso sollen die Bürger
bitte für diese irre Energiewende gleich
doppelt zahlen einmal privat und einmal
für die Unternehmen runter mit den
Energiesteuern Entlastung für alle ist
angesagt wir brauchen mehr
Marktwirtschaft und weniger
ökosozialismus wir brauchen einen
schlanken Staat der die Bürger und die
Unternehmen vor allen Dingen in Ruhe
lässt wir brauchen eine Agenda 20 30 und
eine Regierung die den Mut hatte diese
auch durchzudrücken es geht um unser
Land verdammt noch mal und nicht darum
den eigenen Spezies irgendwelche Jobs
zuzuschanzen
innovative Firmen entstehen dort muss
nicht nur einzelne geniale Köpfe gibt
sondern ein ganzes Land der Zukunft
zugewandt ist kommt sie zum Schluss
ein solches Land zu schaffen liegt in
der Verantwortung der Bundesregierung
und da den versagt sie gerade kläglich
bleibt die Hoffnung dass die nächste
Bundesregierung ist besser macht vielen
Dank
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Daniel rinkert
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren über 4 Millionen direkte und
indirekte Beschäftigte
217 Milliarden brutto Wertschöpfung fast
7% des BIPs das sind die
wirtschaftlichen Strukturdaten des
Tourismus und das auch gut dass wir zum
Abschluss der Debatte hier über die
Perspektiven und die Zukunft des
Tourismus in Deutschland sprechen es
gestern haben wir in der Ampel mit 150
Vertretern und Vertreter aus der Branche
gesprochen dabei haben wir interessante
Gespräche geführt und sie haben genau
wieder gezeigt dass die Branche vor
großen Herausforderungen Umbrüchen und
Veränderung steht Stichwörter sind
Corona
arbeitsprechtkräftebedarf und
zielgerichtete Strategien
und daher möchten wir mal ganz klar
sagen und mich auch stellvertreten
glaube ich für alle DemokratInnen
Demokraten in diesem Haus bedanken bei
den Beschäftigten bedanken die weiter in
der großen Familie des Tourismus
arbeiten den Dank gilt den
Servicekräften in der Gastronomie den
Mitarbeitern im Reisebüro der
Busfahrerin der Reiseveranstalterin den
Technikern bei Konzerten den
betreibenden von Campingplätzen
Freizeitparks und messen
sie merken schon der Tourismus ist eine
breite und vielfältige Branche eine
Branche die vom Einsatz der
Beschäftigten geprägt ist geprägt von
Herzlichkeit Kreativität und
Leidenschaft und diese Eigenschaften
durfte ich als Neuling im Ausschuss als
ich vor ein Jahr eingetreten bin auch
kennen und schätzen lernen und deshalb
sage ich ganz klar der Tourismus stärkt
den ländlichen Raum belebt die
Attraktivität der Innenstädte schafft
gute Arbeit baut Brücken und bringt die
Menschen aller Kulturen und sozialen
Schichten zusammen da ist es wichtig
dass wir als Koalition die
Tourismusbranche unterstützen und gute
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen zuletzt unter
anderem mit dem deutschland-ticket oder
dem fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz und in
Zukunft mit der Abschaffung des
Meldescheins und der umfassenden
nationalen Tourismusstrategie
[Applaus]
für die Gestaltung eben diese
zukunftsfähigen Tourismusbranche und das
ist auch eine Bedeutung für regionale
Strukturen hat das zeigt bei mir der
Rhein-Kreis Neuss noch Tage bauen drei
Tage bauen zukünftig eine ganz große
Seenlandschaft mit dieser kleinen Wand
sehen Landschaft gehen eben auch ganz
große Zukunftschancen einher für den
Tourismusstandort und meine Damen und
Herren mit dieser nationalen
Tourismusstrategie entwickeln wir eben
auch ein Instrument dass du zu beitragen
soll dass Deutschland eine
Vorreiterrolle in Sachen nachhaltigen
Tourismus einnehmen kann das stärkt den
Standort unterstützt die
Tourismusbranche und bringt neues
Wachstum von daher freue ich mich auf
die Beratung hier zum tourismushaushalt
und wünsche noch eine gute Woche
weitere Worten Meldungen liegen zu
diesem Einzelplan nicht vor
wir können deshalb
zum nächsten Geschäftsbereich
übergehen dem Geschäftsbereich des
Bundesministeriums für Gesundheit
ich bitte Sie entsprechend zügig
die Plätze zu tauschen und die
fachpolitikerinnen und
fachpolitikpolitiker die entsprechenden
Plätze einzunehmen
bitte nehmen Sie Platz
und ich eröffne hier mit die Debatte und
das Wort hat für die Bundesregierung der
Bundesminister für Gesundheit dr Karl
Lauterbach
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen der
Bundeshaushalt für Gesundheit ist der am
stärksten Schrumpf in der
gesundheitshaushalt den wir lange gehabt
haben der stärkste Beitrag zur
Konsolidierung des Haushalts insgesamt
das ist aber nur darauf zurückzuführen
dass die hohen pandemiekosten jetzt
nicht mehr anfallen der Haushalt wächst
im Vergleich zu der Zeit vor Corona
somit haben wir keinen insgesamt
schrumpfenden Haushalt sondern einen
sich stabilisierenden Haushalt wir haben
einen Haushalt der mit dazu beigetragen
hat dass Deutschland im Vergleich zu
vielen anderen europäischen Ländern
besser durch die Pandemie gekommen ist
mit einer geringeren Sterblichkeit mit
weniger schweren Verläufen das ist die
Leistung der fehlende Wesen der
Pflegerinnen der Ärztinnen auch der
Apothekerinnen der Medizinischen
Fachangestellten der fehlen die da im
Hintergrund geholfen haben ich möchte
mich an dieser Stelle noch einmal ganz
herzlich bedanken das war eine
großartige gemeinsame Leistung auf die
dieses Land stolz sein kann
wir sind jetzt wieder zurück bei den
Alltagsaufgaben und bei den
Alltagsaufgaben muss man sagen was ist
der Status derzeit leider ist das
deutsche Gesundheitssystem um in der
Sprache der Medizin zu bleiben chronisch
krank wir haben im Vergleich zu anderen
europäischen Ländern die höchsten
Ausgaben gemessen am Sozialprodukt wir
haben die höchsten Ausgaben für die
Krankenhausversorgung im Vergleich zu
anderen europäischen Ländern wir haben
sehr hohe Ausgaben in allen Bereichen
wir haben aber leider keine gute
Ergebnisqualität die Lebenserwartung hat
sich in Deutschland nicht so gut
entwickelt als dass wir eine
Lebenserwartung hätten wie
beispielsweise Frankreich Italien
Spanien Portugal oder Schweden oder
Finnland oder Norwegen wir haben
mittlerweile so große
der 14 in der Lebenserwartung das
darüber international geschrieben wird
wir haben auch sehr große Unterschiede
in der Lebenserwartung zwischen reiche
und arm wenn man das unterste fünfte mit
dem obersten Fünftel vergleicht ist bei
Männern die Lebenserwartung im untersten
fünfte zehn Jahre kürzer somit haben wir
von der Ergebnisqualität haben wir ein
erhebliches Problem ein Problem über
welches jetzt auch international viel
geschrieben wird woran liegt das haben
wir schlechtere Ärzte haben wir
schlechtere Pflegekräfte sind die Leute
nicht motiviert ganz im Gegenteil wir
haben erstklassige Forschung wir haben
erstklassige Ärztinnen wir haben hoch
motivierte Pflegekräfte aber wir haben
einen Reformstau wir haben einen
Reformstaus hat mehr als 10 Jahren das
kann man sagen es sind doch ständig
Reformen gemacht worden wie oft sind die
Reformen vorgetragen worden es waren im
Großen und Ganzen muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen
bagatellreformen Reformen mit einer
großen Überschrift aber kleiner Wirkung
da sind wir zurückgefahren und wir
fahren weiter zurück und ich will ein
paar Beispiele bringen wir haben im
Krankenhaus Sektor die Situation wir
haben sehr viel Bürokratie wir haben
geringe Qualität im Vergleich zu
internationalen Benchmarks insbesondere
der spitzenversorgung krebsversorgung
zum Beispiel und wir haben darüber
hinaus auch ein durch und durch
ökonomisiertes System die Ökonomie
bestimmt das System daher brauchen wir
schon seit zehn Jahren eine große
krankenhausreform wir brauchen einen Weg
von der Ökonomie zurück zu der
eigentlichen Medizin zurück zu einer
evidenzbasierten Medizin diese Reform
seit zehn Jahren überfällig machen wir
jetzt gemeinsam wir werden die Medizin
wieder in den Vordergrund rücken und wer
noch die kleinen Krankenhäuser erhalten
sie würden ohne diese Reform stellen wir
werden das heute immer wieder hören die
kleinen Krankenhäuser würden von uns
vernichten das ist falsch wir geben den
kleinen Krankenhäusern eine
existenzperspektive gegen den kleinen
Krankenhäusern eine
existenzperspektive ohne diese Reform
würden sie nicht durchkommen seit zehn
Jahren reden wir über die
Digitalisierung was ist passiert wir
haben keine elektronisches Rezept wir
haben keine elektronische Patientenakte
wir haben keine digitalisierte Forschung
auch das gehen wir jetzt konsequent an
wir machen zwei große digitale Gesetze
wir werden die elektronische
Patientenakte für die
versorgungsbewässerung haben für eine
bessere Krebsbehandlung wir werden die
beste Struktur für internationale
Gesundheitsforschung mit digitalen Daten
auch mit den Verfahren der künstlichen
Intelligenz hat wir kommen später an den
Staat wir nutzen aber im Prinzip die
neuen Erkenntnisse um unmittelbar in den
modernenste Strategie aufsetzen zu
können das werden wir angehen die
digitalisierungsreform wird kommen
sagt zehn Jahren wird hier im Haus
darüber geklagt dass wir Lieferengpässe
haben zehn Jahre lang ist gearbeitet
worden Gipfel werden gemacht man kommt
zusammen man spricht man beklagt das
große Leid es passiert danach nicht wir
haben seit zehn Jahren leaf dass wir
müssen die Produktion noch Europa und
nach Deutschland zurückholen das dafür
notwendige Gesetz haben wir gemacht
jetzt wird beklagt das Gesetz wird noch
nicht ja wundern es dauert natürlich
zwei Jahre bis die neuen Fabriken
aufgebaut sind wir sind es aber
angegangen diejenigen die heute beklagen
es wird noch nicht wirken und wir werden
die kurzfristigen Probleme ebenfalls im
Herbst lösen können Panik mache hilft
dann nicht weiter wir werden die
Probleme lösen können aber diejenigen
die heute heute wieder Klagen werden
haben zehn Jahre lang auf Gipfeltreffen
das Problem
festgestellt haben nie etwas gemacht wir
lösen das Problem und holen die
Produktion nach Deutschland nach Europa
nach Europa zurück
wir haben in der Forschung den Anschluss
verloren in Deutschland werden ständig
weniger klinische Studien gemacht
mittlerweile ist die Situation die wenn
in Deutschland was sehr häufig der Fall
ist eine Grundlage Errungenschaft
durchgesetzt wird wir haben top Forscher
dann ist es so dass in Deutschland die
klinische Studie erst komplett genehmigt
ist zu dem Zeitpunkt wo sie in den
Vereinigten Staaten schon durchgeführt
wurde somit verlieren wir wir waren
immer teuer wir waren immer gründlich
aber wir sind zu langsam wir brauchen
daher und wir werden das bringen was
seit zehn Jahren fehlt ein Medizin
forschungsgesetz um den Standort für
gute Pharmaforschung attraktiver zu
machen so dass die Produkte die von
unseren grundlagenwissenschaftlern
entdeckt werden dass die auch in
Deutschland entwickelt werden und in
Deutschland zum Schluss produziert
werden können wir brauchen hier
Wachstumskerne mit einer Wertschöpfung
die gleichzeitig auch die Versorgung
besser macht dieses seit zehn Jahren
notwendige Medizin forschungsgesetz
werden wir auf den Weg bringen
und schließlich
seit zehn Jahren wird darüber debattiert
wie wir es heute wieder hören die
Notfall die
notfallversorgungsambulanz und sind zu
voll das sind die falschen Patienten die
Rettungsdienste fahren die falschen
Kliniken an das System ist
unübersichtlich die Leute warten Stunden
wir brauchen eine notfallreform eine
rettungsdienstreform seit zehn Jahren
höre ich das seit zehn Jahren wird es
beklagt es gibt immer wieder Gipfel
immer wieder treffen wir machen jetzt
zum ersten Mal eine konsequente große
notdienstreform und eine
rettungsdienstreform sodass wir endlich
die Patienten die ins Krankenhaus müssen
auch wenn das richtige Krankenhaus
bringen aber die ja diejenigen die gar
nicht ins Krankenhaus müssen dass die
auch ambulant versorgt werden können so
dass die Notdienste nicht verstopft sind
von Patienten die dort überhaupt nicht
hingehört seit zehn Jahren brauchen wir
diese Form und schließlich das
Wichtigste ich habe eben am Anfang
gesagt das Wichtigste was wir lösen
müssen ist das Problem bei der geringen
Lebenserwartung da der schlechten
Entwicklung der Lebenserwartung wir
brauchen ein neues Institut an Institut
für öffentliche Gesundheit ein Bier wir
brauchen ein Institut was nur ein
einziges Ziel hat über bessere
Vorsorgemedizin über bessere Vorbeugung
die großen
lebenserwartungsdefizite die durch
mangelnde Vorbeugung in Deutschland
entstehen diese zu beseitigen dieses
Institut auch seit mehr als zehn Jahren
dringend notwendig dieses Institut
werden wir in diesem Herbst auf den Weg
bringen das werden wir als Ampel
gemeinsam machen nicht danke allen
Beteiligten für die gute Zusammenarbeit
in der Gesundheitspolitik kann ich nur
sagen die Ampel wird sie wird durch
Geschlossenheit und dafür möchte ich
ganz herzlich danken
Sepp Müller für die CDU CSU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren Herr Minister
seitdem sie Gesundheitsminister sind
werden die Problemstellen im
Gesundheitswesen immer größer was wir
jetzt brauchen ist eine gesundheitswende
und ich habe sehr aufmerksam ihrem
Redebeitrag gelauscht und auffällig ist
ja nicht das was Sie gesagt haben und
beschrieben haben sondern auffällig ist
das über was sie nicht gesprochen haben
über was haben sie nicht gesprochen wo
bleiben Ihre versprochenen 100 Millionen
Euro für
long-cfs Betroffene wir haben zwei
Anträge erarbeitet und in den Bundestag
eingebracht sie haben das angekündigt
das umzusetzen und was haben Sie am Ende
gemacht unsere beiden Anträge abgelehnt
sie sind der ankündigungsminister und
nichts mehr
über was haben sie auch nicht gesprochen
Herr Minister über ihren sogenannten
hitzeplan sie werden ja nicht nur jetzt
corona-minister genannt sondern
hitzminister anstatt sich über hitzetote
richtigerweise zu beklagen sind sie
heute auch nicht ein einziges Mal auf
die größte Todesursache in Deutschland
eingegangen das sind die
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen diese
Herz-Kreislauf auf Erkrankungen sind die
Todesursache Nummer eins wir haben in
den Deutschen Bundestag einen Antrag
eingebracht für mehr Prävention durch
Sport was hat ihre Ampel gemacht sie hat
nicht nur den Antrag abgelehnt im
Gegenteil sie kürzen um 79 Prozent die
Präventionsarbeit in ihrem Haushalt sie
sind der Minister der nur ankündigt und
nicht liefert Herr Lauterbach sie
versagen auf ganzer Strecke
und interessant ist ja auch über was der
sogenannte Gesundheitsminister nicht
gesprochen hat sie werden die Droge
Cannabis legalisieren sie werden und
wollen das in jedem Kinder- und
Jugendzimmer bubatz jetzt legal ist sie
machen das was junge Menschen krank
macht was andere sagen und uns auch
zeigen und dass die Aufregung hier bei
der Ampel so groß ist kann ich ja
nachvollziehen weil manchmal braucht man
anscheinend solche Drogen um ihre
Politik zu ertragen aber nicht nur die
Politiker hier von der Union sondern die
SPD Innenminister die Polizisten die
Kinder und Jugendpsychologen sagen ihn
lassen Sie die Finger davon stecken sie
mehr in Prävention und hören Sie auf
Cannabis zu legalisieren mit uns als
Union wird ist das nicht geben
und über was sie auch nicht gesprochen
haben Herr Minister sie loben die
Pfleger sie loben die Pflegerin sie
sprechen kein Wort über die pflegenden
Angehörigen viereinhalb Millionen
Menschen in unserem Land sind pflegende
Angehöriger was machen sie mit ihrem
behörnchen
45 Euro mehr das ist lächerlicher
Minister das ist lächerlich was sie
machen
im Gegenteil dieser Bundeshaushalt sieht
die Kürzung und die Streichung des
Bundeszuschusses in die
Pflegeversicherung vor sie machen nicht
nur sich lächerlich sondern sie machen
Pflege teurer das ist die ampelpolitik
im Gesundheitswesen Herr Minister
und ganz interessant und bei aller
Ernsthaftigkeit wegen den Todeszahlen da
gebe ich Ihnen Recht insbesondere was
das Thema Klinikbetten anbelangt muss
und sollte man eine krankenhausreform
auf den Weg bringen das stimmt und ihr
Regierungschef hat gestern einen Pakt
angekündigt dass wir gemeinsam uns auf
den Weg machen die großen Reform dieses
Landes anzugehen und ja da gehört zu
einer krankenhausreform sicherlich dazu
aber ich kann für die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion sagen wer
Verträge zulassen Dritter macht mit den
krankenaustransparenzgesetz eine
Bürokratie auf Krankenhäuser und Länder
überbordet und gleichzeitig unsere
Zustimmung in Bundesrat erwartet der hat
den Schuss noch nicht gehört Herr
Minister mit uns geht es nur gemeinsam
in allen Bereichen oder gar nicht seien
Sie sich sicher
[Applaus]
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat jetzt das
Wort die Kollegin Dr Paula
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer lieber
selbst ich leiste ja immer gerade auch
in den Reihen meiner Fraktion viel
Aufklärungsarbeit wenn ich wenn ich
erkläre dass der Sepp zwar Sepp heißt
aber nicht aus Bayern kommt und nicht
von der CSU ist aber wenn du jetzt
solche Reden hältst wird halt auch für
mich zu dem schwer das glaubwürdig in
meiner eigenen Fraktion zu erklären
und ich habe so ein bisschen wenn ich
mir auch die Rednerin Liste jetzt
anschaue wenn ich sehe wer hier auf der
Länderbank sitzt obwohl ich es
grundsätzlich sehr sehr gut finde dass
die Länder hier vertreten sind dann habe
ich so ein bisschen Angst dass es in
dieser haushaltsrunde jetzt hier im
Einzelplan 15 in den nächsten Minuten
und auch in den vergangenen Minuten ja
schon gesehen nicht so viel im Haushalt
gehen wird und deswegen gestatten Sie
mir als vielleicht eine der wenigen
tatsächlich einmal auf diesen
Haushaltsentwurf konkret zu schauen der
Minister hat gesagt wir leisten hier mit
dem Einzelplan 15 mit den größten
Konsolidierungsbeitrag zum
Bundeshaushalt so kann man das
formulieren aber natürlich wissen wir
alle auch aus der Koalition das ist kein
schöner Haushalt das ist kein Haushalt
wo man den Freundschaft ja ausbricht
wenn man den hier im Parlament
einbringen und vertreten und diskutieren
muss aber zur Wahrheit gehört auch wir
haben hier in dieser personellen
Konstellation eben auch Haushalte in den
letzten zwei Jahren beraten die brutal
groß waren für das was der Einzelplan 15
normalerweise tut nämlich eigentlich im
Wesentlichen nur wenige Aufgaben
übernehmen und den gesetzlichen Zuschuss
zur gesetzlichen Kranken regeln wir
kommen im Jahr 2022 von dem Haushalt mit
über 66 Milliarden das war auch für uns
das war eine riesengroße ungewohnte
Summe wir haben im aktuellen
Haushaltsjahr 24,5 Milliarden und ja
jetzt geht es noch mal sehr erheblich
zurück auf 16,5 Milliarden das ist noch
deutlich über dem präpandemischen Niveau
aber ja zur Wahrheit gehört auch dazu
das ist fast auf dem präpandemischen
Niveau und wenn man sich jetzt anschaut
das aber trotzdem auch wenn Corona ein
wesentlichen Teilen vorbei ist neue
Aufgaben hinzugekommen sind und hier um
die teuersten zu nennen die Pandemie
bereitschaftsverträge und die zentrale
Beschaffung der Impfkosten der
Impfstoffe dann ist es so dass
tatsächlich dieser Haushalt obwohl er
fast so groß ist wie der vor der
Pandemie erhebliche zusätzliche Aufgaben
leisten muss
und wenn wir eines betrachten müssen was
der Bundesrechnungshof uns
richtigerweise aufgeschrieben hat ist
dass dann die zentralen Kosten für die
Beschaffung der Impfstoffe und es ist
gut dass wir gemeinsam als Europäer mit
den Herstellern verhandelt haben dass
wir weniger abnehmen müssen und dass wir
das über die nächsten Jahre Strecken das
bedeutet aber auch dass die Kosten die
dafür immer noch im dreistelligen
Millionenbereich jetzt für zwei Jahre
anfallen auf Haushalte fallen die
deutlich weniger Volumen haben und das
gehört dazu die auch einmal zu nennen
2024 werden wir 346 Millionen dafür
aufwenden müssen und im Folgejahr 380
Millionen diesen aktuell nicht im
Haushalt abgebildet da erwarten auch wir
als Haushälter kabinettseitig dass das
nachgeholt wird bis zum Ende der
Beratung weil ich muss hier den
Bundesrechnungshof den ich zitiere
zustimmen notwendige Ausgaben für
eingegangene Verpflichtung von
erheblicher finanzieller Bedeutung
sollten eindeutig im Einzelplan
abgebildet sein meine Damen und Herren
und das bedeutet auch für uns als
Parlament dass wir das mit Nachdruck
einfordern werden
das was abgebildet ist sind die
zusätzlichen Aufwendungen für die
pandemiebereitschaftsverträge der
Minister hat darüber gesprochen auch
seit Müller hat es darüber gesprochen
was ist eigentlich mit der
pharmazeutischen Produktion die Pandemie
bereitschaftsverträge über die wird viel
zu wenig gesprochen aber über zwei
Milliarden Euro bis 2029 wenden wir ja
auf und mit fünf Herstellern hier in
Deutschland
impfstoffproduktionskapazitäten im Land
aufzubauen und ja da beginnt jetzt der
Hochlauf wir hatten im aktuellen Jahr
dafür nur
156,4 Millionen aufzuwenden aber das
läuft jetzt hoch und im kommenden Jahr
sind es
544,8 Millionen wenn man sieht dass der
Gesamthaushalt nur knapp über 16
Milliarden haben wird und davon 14
einhalb Milliarden schon gebunden sind
für den Zuschuss an die KV dann sieht
man was das für eine erhebliche
Belastung ist und die ist im
Kernhaushalt für das Rücken von
Produktion für den Aufbau von
Produktionskapazitäten auch in
Sachsen-Anhalt lieber
der Einzelplan 15 für das nächste Jahr
ich habe schon gesagt der enthält jetzt
nicht so wahnsinnig viele
freudennachrichten die krankenhausreform
und alle anderen Themen die hier gleich
noch sehr emotional nur als Vorwarnung
an die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
diskutiert werden die sind da gar nicht
mit drin enthalten aber was noch drin
enthalten ist war ja auch das Thema
lonkovic schon angesprochen wurde auf
der einen Seite sind Forschungsmittel
enthalten wenn auch nicht in der Höhe
von 100 Millionen Euro und auf der
anderen Seite wird etwas fortgeführt was
wir als Parlament als Erfolg in den
letzten Beratungen vor einem Jahr in den
Haushalt mit reingeschrieben haben
nämlich in der aktuellen Situation wo es
für viele Betroffene oder fraglich
Betroffene von und Kurve zu schwierig
ist gute von unseriösen Informationen
und Beratungsangeboten für und zu
unterscheiden beim BMG eine Hotline
aufzubauen die genau diese Beratung und
Vermittlung von Patientinnen und
Patienten übernehmen kann wir hatten 600
000 € eingestellt aktuell kann es
fortgeführt werden deutlich preiswerter
weil wir festgestellt haben es braucht
nicht ganz so viel Geld dafür und ich
freue mich dass an der Stelle mit den
200.000 € für diese Beratung hier das
Parlament einmal mehr sehr sehr gutes
Projekt rein verhandelt hat und es wird
auch in diesem schwierigen Haushalt
wieder der Fall sein da freue ich mich
vor allen Dingen wenn der Stadler und
Karsten kleindorf den besten mit
Berichterstattern die man diese Sachen
haben kann vielen Dank
Wolfgang widerspricht jetzt für die AFD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geschätzte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Gesundheit
ist ein sehr hohes Gut der Staat muss
die Gesundheit seiner Bürger schützen
aber er darf ihnen nicht mit dem Wort
Gesundheit im Munde die Freiheit nehmen
große Verantwortung für die Gesundheit
der Bürger trägt der Staat bei den
Krankenhäusern eine gute
krankenhausreform wird im besten Fall
die Versorgung verbessert und zugleich
Geld sparen wenn ihre Reform Herr
Minister obwohl sie das bestreiten wie
wir gehört haben aber für viele Kliniken
auf dem Lande das ausbringt dann
bedeutet dann bedroht das die Versorgung
in Notfällen wie bei Herzinfarkt
gerade aus der Sicht von Flächenländern
wie auch meiner Heimat Bayern muss man
davor lautstark warnen
[Applaus]
die corona-pandemie ist vorbei aktuell
werden freilich wieder Impfstoffe
ausgeliefert natürlich wer will kann
sich impfen lassen aber die Bürger
müssen auch über die Risiken aufgeklärt
werden ständig gibt es neue Berichte
über Impfschäden wo bleibt die Offensive
Aufklärung durch staatliche Stellen auf
welcher Seite steht eigentlich die
Regierung auf der Seite der Bürger oder
auf der Seite der Pharmaindustrie
dass man über die EU viel zu viel
Impfstoff eingekauft hat ist trotz der
Nachverhandlung immer noch eine
Riesenlast wenn jetzt die aktualisierten
Impfstoffe kommen werden wieder
Millionen alte Dosen in den Lagern
ablaufen und weggeworfen das Herz des
Steuerzahlers muss bluten angesichts
dieser Verschwendung
im Zusammenhang mit den pfeifferdeals
von Kommissionspräsidenten von der Leyen
wird außerdem vom größten Korruptions
Skandal der Geschichte gesprochen auf
der supernationalen Ebene ist der Lobby
Einfluss besonders groß und
intransparent das sollte uns zu denken
geben ganz besonders in transparent ist
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation die WHO
diese wird aus dem Bundeshaushalt mit
Geldern gerade zu verwöhnt und bei
Fragen nach den Vorgängen dort hört man
aus der Regierung nur
ohrenbetäubendes schweigen
das kann und darf nicht so bleiben
wir braut sich nämlich eine riesen
Gefahr für Demokratie und Freiheit
zusammen ist darf der WHO nicht gelingen
sich im Namen der Gesundheit umfassende
Rechte anzueignen die die Verfassungen
der Mitgliedstaaten aushebeln natürlich
spreche ich von dem sogenannten
pandemievertrag der gerade in
Verhandlung ist
die WHO unterliegt keiner Kontrolle kann
aber den Pandemiefall ausrufen und dann
in alle beteiligten Staaten
hineinregieren Grundrechte wie
Bewegungsfreiheit Reisefreiheit
Berufsfreiheit und Informationsfreiheit
könnten aufgehoben werden eine
Medienzensur droht gegen angebliche
Falschinformationen und was das sein
soll liegt der WHO fest die geplanten
Vertragswerke Öffnen der Willkür Tür und
Tor
Demokratie und Freiheit kann nur der
Rechtsstaat garantieren aber keine
überstaatliche Organisation die solche
Prinzipien gar nicht kennt
wer einen solchen pandemievertrag
abschließt gibt grundlegende
Verfassungsrechte auf das darf die
Bundesregierung niemals tun
machen sie die Verhandlungen zum
pandemievertrag endlich transparent
steigen Sie aus wenn auch nur ein
Grundrecht in Gefahr kommt schützen Sie
das Grundgesetz
wenn sich die WHO zu einem übergriffigen
monstrumentwickelt dann ist es höchste
Zeit alle Zahlungen an sie zu überprüfen
hier ist auch über die
Haushaltsberatungen hinaus höchste
Wachsamkeit geworden
[Applaus]
klein für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Minister
ist darauf eingegangen ja nominell
schrumpft kein Haushalt kein Einzelplan
zu stark wie der des BMGS vor allem auch
prozentual aber das liegt natürlich
daran dass auch in diesem Haushalt für
die Planung 24 wieder corona-ausgaben
aus dem Haushalt rauswachsen und ich
glaube das ist nur konsequent für das
Thema impfstoffversorgung aber auch für
Zuschüsse an die Pflegeversicherung und
an die Krankenversicherung natürlich
sinken auch ein Stück weit die Mittel
für die internationale Gesundheit aber
auch das sind folgen weil eben
corona-maßnahmen Auslaufen
impfstoffkampagnen natürlich jetzt auch
eingestellt werden trotzdem ist
Deutschland nach wie vor stark
international engagiert darüber glaube
ich gibt's auch innerhalb demokratischen
Spektrums überhaupt keinen Zweifel dass
wir natürlich international gemeinsam
Krankheiten Pandemien bekämpfen müssen
unterwegs ich fand es schon wieder
bemerkenswert ist ja nicht das erste Mal
die AFD macht es bei allen
Haushaltsberatungen im Bereich des BMWs
ich will ihn aber noch mal zurufen
Krankheiten machen an Grenzen keinen
sie können die Grenzen hochziehen wie
sie wollen
die Krankheitserreger kommen trotzdem
rein deshalb ist es für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von eminenter
Bedeutung dass die Bundesregierung sich
international stark engagiert um
pandemieausbreitungen zu verhindern
und auch wenn es in ihrem
youtube-schnipsel sicher nicht vorkommen
wird möchte ich doch darauf hinweisen
dass was sie über die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation gesagt haben
welche Eingriffsrechte die bei uns im
Grundtechnik hatten das ist einfach
Grund falsch ja das haben sie sich
ausgedacht das ist ein Märchen das ist
mit nichten so über Grundrechte
Einschränkungen entscheidet der Deutsche
Bundestag nur hier wenn diese
Entscheidung getroffen und nirgendwo
sonst und das soll auch so bleiben
jetzt geht der Haushalt wie gesagt
nominell zurück aber im Vergleich zum
Vorkrisenjahr 2019 haben wir natürlich
trotzdem noch ein Anstieg und die
Kollegin pischotter ist ja schon dr
fischotta ist ja schon mal drauf
angegangen wir werden natürlich über die
Prioritäten setzen Herr Minister
intensiv gemeinsam diskutieren im
berichterstatterkreis insgesamt aber vor
allem natürlich auch mit meinen
hervorragend mit Berichterstatterin aus
der Ampel und dann natürlich wird sich
am Ende herausstellen ob die
Prioritätensetzung auch so bleibt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind uns
alle sehr bewusst über die großen
Herausforderungen der sozialen
Sicherungssysteme die Ausgaben auch in
der Krankenversicherung in der
Pflegeversicherung steigen jedes Jahr
gabi hat an die Ausgabe die die
Sozialausgaben vor dem Bund beträgt im
Haushalt 2024
7,47,9% Tendenz immer steigend und die
Gründe sind natürlich demografischer
Wandel und vor allem bei der
Krankenversicherung technologischer
Fortschritt aber es kann am Ende nicht
sein dass diese Steigerungen am Ende nur
wieder auf Rücken der jungen Generation
ausgetragen werden das ist mit den
Freien Demokraten nicht zu machen und
deshalb müssen wir natürlich über die
Strukturen sprechen der Minister sie
haben ja auch einige Maßnahmen
angesprochen da ist natürlich die
Kostenstruktur innerhalb der Systeme
selbst das sind auch die
Selbstverwaltungen gefordert aber zur
Wahrheit gehört dazu dass wir auch
darüber sprechen müssen wir jetzige
Leistungsumfang in Zukunft finanziert
wird und ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt
ist
dass wir noch mal ausgiebig über die
klaren Zuständigkeiten im
Gesundheitssystem diskutieren müssen und
ob diejenigen die dort verantwortlich
sind auch dieser Verantwortung gerecht
werden hier sprechen wir vor allem im
Bereich der Krankenhausfinanzierung wir
diskutieren ja sehr intensiv die
krankenhausreform und ich begrüße es
ausdrücklich dass ein Vertreter der
Länder heute anwesend ist denn ich denke
es sind einige Fragen die heute
beantwortet werden können zum Beispiel
warum haben es die länderzeit
Jahrzehnten unterlassen ordentliche
Strukturreformen vorzunehmen um die
Krankenhäuser auf die heutige Situation
vorzubereiten warum investieren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die länderzeit
Jahren viel zu wenig Geld in unsere
Krankenhäuser das ist die originäre
Zuständigkeit der Bundesländer liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diese nicht stattfindenden Investitionen
sorgen für großen Druck auch auf den
Bundeszuschuss und auf den
Bundeshaushalt und ich denke Herr
Minister holiday hat auch gekommen um
sich dafür zu bedanken dass die
Bundesregierung in der corona-krise zum
Beispiel 20 Milliarden Euro
Ausgleichszahlungen an die Krankenhäuser
ausgegeben hat persönliche
Schutzausrüstung beschafft hat oder
Impfstoffe und vieles mehr ich denke das
wäre auch in der corona-krise gut
gewesen aber besser spät als nie aber
auch in der jetzigen Krise Herr Minister
Herr Staatsminister unterstützt der
wohnt die Krankenhäuser erheblich mit
dem Härtefall vor in WSF in
wirtschaftstabilitätsraum mit sechs
Milliarden Euro hinzukommen die Mittel
der Bremsen und auch Bayern hat ja schon
dieses Jahr die Krankenhäuser in Bayern
263 Millionen Euro ausgeschüttet
bekommen also ich denke das sind alles
gute Nachrichten die sich sicher im
Wahlkampf in Bayern auch mit der
Bundesregierung verbinden werden aber
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die schwierige Lage in denen sich die
Krankenhäuser befinden auch in Bayern
sind eben verursacht worden weil diese
Investitionen unterblieben sind allein
im Bund seit 2014 bleibt solchen
Ärzteblatt 17 Milliarden Euro die
Beträge sind auch in den letzten
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr angestiegen
sondern sogar geschrumpft 1991 haben die
Länder noch 3,6 Milliarden Euro
ausgegeben für krankenhausinvestitionen
2021 nur noch 3,2 Milliarden Euro und da
ist die Inflation noch gar nicht
gegengerechnet das gleiche Bild leider
auch in Bayern 1,9 Milliarden Euro seit
2014 nicht getätigte
Investitionsförderung 1991 haben sie
noch 664 Millionen Euro für die
Krankenhausfinanzierung eingeplant
aktuell nur 643 sie haben ja jetzt zwei
Wahlkampf diesen großes Programm
angekündigt wir glaubt besonders
glaubwürdig ist das allerdings leider
nicht und da möchte ich am Ende auch
noch auf eines Hinweisen aus Sicht eines
bayerischen Steuerzahlers und
Kommunalpolitiker muss man immer noch
sehen dass bei der
Krankenhausfinanzierung in Bayern zum
helfen die Kommunen den Beitrag leisten
müssen und die sind sowieso schon nicht
schwieriger Lage deshalb glaube ich gut
wenn Sie heute in den klare Aussagen
machen würden das auch der Freistaat
Bayern sich die CSU geführte
Staatsregierung konstruktiv an der
krankenhausreform beteiligt in Zukunft
denn das brauchen die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land vielen Dank
die Kollegin Dr Gesine Lötsch hat jetzt
das Wort für die Fraktion gelingt
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren nach ihrer
Rede Herr Lauterbach hätte man ja denken
müssen sie sind neu in der Politik die
Wahrheit ist aber die SPD ist seit 1998
mit einer Unterbrechung von vier Jahren
in der Regierung also für alles mit
verantwortlich aber das ist ja schon die
ganze Woche so die SPD tut so als hätte
sie in den vergangenen Jahren keine
Verantwortung getragen und das stimmt
definitiv nicht meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung will reihenweise
kommunale Krankenhäuser schließen sie
nennen es Reform ich nenne es gezielte
Zerstörung unseres öffentlichen
Gesundheitssystems und dieser Wahnsinn
muss gestoppt werden meine Damen und
Herren
wir wollen eine solidarische
Bürgerversicherung kleine Erinnerung das
stand auch in den Wahlprogrammen von SPD
und Grünen
sagen sie doch wenigstens mit dem ersten
Schritt an erhöhen sie die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze auf das Niveau
der Rentenversicherung dann hätten wir
das gleiche Niveau und wir hätten 18
Milliarden mehr Euro in den Kassen das
wäre ein gerechter und solidarischer
Schritt meine Damen und Herren
unser Gesundheitssystem befindet sich in
einem dauerhaft Notbetrieb die
corona-krise steckt im
Gesundheitspersonal in den Knochen die
Krankenhäuser sind dauerhaft
unterfinanziert doch die Bundesregierung
sagt erst die Schuldenbremse dann die
Gesundheit und das ist der falsche Weg
meine Damen und Herren
der Bundes
Zuschuss der Kranken
Versicherung soll 2024 auf dem Niveau
von 2023 eingefroren werden angesichts
der hohen Inflation bedeutet das real
weniger Geld das wird zu steigen